[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello it is blitz day at the st louis
chess club and
biggest blitz day we can imagine we have
the legend himself gary kasparov in town
here at the central west end we had him
in our commentary booth a couple days
ago and now we're going to see him
throwing down on the chessboard in
action jennifer nice to be here with you
that's right i'm jennifer shahadi and
i'm with yasser sarwan and maurice
ashley and we're going to be covering
all three hours of this exciting back
and forth
well for a blitz challenge you couldn't
ask for anything better than this and
look at the lineup of what we have
that's right we've got gary castro and
the top three finishers from the u.s
championship lucky for us they're also
the top three raided in the tournament
and among the top three players
in the top 10 players in the world right
fabiano caruana number two in the world
and the reigning us chess champion
nakamura a blitz legend it's great to
see him in the mix and of course wesley
so
who's been getting better and better
fantastic player breaking in the top ten
he has reached as high as a top five but
we're looking at this year as being a
breakout year for wesley this is an
extraordinary field of players
and let's take a look at today's blitz
format where we've got a five minute
plus three second delay
no increment that means and the
interesting thing about a delay is it's
use it or lose it so in a way there's no
point in making a move in one second
except to rattle your opponent right but
take those extra three seconds before
the clock starts
ticking down and it will always stick
down there will never there be no time
added that's right and we've got three
round robins a day so that's nine games
a day and we're gonna see the exact same
format tomorrow
so a lot of action for you guys watching
at home we have a total of fifty
thousand dollars in prizes
nice and so a nice little cherry on the
top of the prizes that these players
already took home for their excellent
results in the championship including of
course 50k for fabiano
one nice thing here is that gary
kasparov generously agreed to donate any
prizes he wins
to the olympic team the united states
lincoln olympic team which is going to
be
the strongest olympic team we've ever
had yeah very very appreciated gesture
by gary that's right and we've got
maurice ashley with a closer look on all
the players that we have today
well this is one of the greatest blitz
exhibitions on u.s soil ever you have
these illustrious players playing at the
top of their game except one guy who of
course many call the top player of all
time
well our host gary kasparov now 53 years
young one of the greatest players ever
maybe
the greatest player ever certainly a
fantastic performer last year he played
in a blitz event against nigel short and
simply decimated his opposition showing
that he still has the skills to play
blitz chess we'll see if he's in fine
form today but his opposition will
indeed be fierce first of all the number
two player in the world and the now
reigning u.s champion fabiano caruana 23
years old a shooting star still rising
he'll be someday world champion
according to many of his fans but it's
going to be blitz for him today he
showed what he could do against nakamura
in the showdown in st louis so he is
definitely one of the favorites to win
this event and wesley so the winner of
the millionaire chess open 2014 he has
been now entrenched in the top 10 in the
world many might consider him an
outsider here in this event but his fans
will say wesley is simply a natural
genius and will be vying for to win some
games take some scalps today
and of course hikaru nakamura
number two in the world right now in
blitz rating a demon in bullet chests he
could play with the best of them and so
fast so quick
lightning speed is not good never really
in any kind of trouble in terms of the
clock many are building him as the clear
favorite in this event we will see what
happens as the players have to show
their blitz skills and they are seated
at the tables ready to play this is
going to be an exciting event this is
going to be so great and right off the
bat i would like to say
wesley wins the um outfit of the day
the pink and the black gotta love it
true that but i don't like the fact he's
winning wearing a jacket of course you
might say
looking handsome and dapper wearing a
jacket is fine but in blitz i tell you
what the short sleeve shirt
much much better you don't want your
arms to be restrained well that's right
and luckily though yeah sir we are not
playing bullet jess if we were of course
nakamura would be a massive favorite
and we've actually
got tony rich
international arbiter and executive
director here at the saint louis chess
club to open up the day's play
welcome to the ultimate blitz challenge
here in st louis missouri we are just
about to begin round one as the players
face off pairings for round one will be
grand master akara nakamura versus grand
master fabiano caruana and grand master
gary kasparov versus grandmaster wesley
so
reminder spectators no talking
please make sure that everything's on
silent uh including cameras
photography's allowed just no flash
players remember not to speak to anybody
else during your games
um
yeah
okay i wish everybody the very best of
luck and with our chief arbiter's
permission
you may begin
saw gary in beast mode there didn't you
i mean 53 years but that competitive
fire
is extraordinary that that look is it
it's pretty scary it says it all right
his death stare is is nothing to mess
with i mean the only one who has
anything on there is nakamura but let's
take a look and see what happened in the
opening it looks like a scotch and the
players are not you see they're not used
to that delay as they're playing
instantly and as you said jen lose it
use it or lose it and they're just
playing really rapid fire instead of
using all of their three seconds well
they know the openings though right now
they don't really need to use the three
seconds to
reassess anything obviously gary was
convinced he was going to play this
version of scotch that he used to defeat
anatoly karpov in their epic world
championship match
clearly wesley was prepared for this
line as well and now wesley giving quite
a bit of pause as gary has not used any
time so far to get to this position
exactly well in fact there are two two
moves for
uh wesley either d7 d6 or knight b4
there's just simply no other choice
other
moves are just strategically really
terrible uh for wesley so
d6 and
black white has an option of going no i
actually he must play knight b4 doesn't
he wow he's just introduced this move c5
that looks
really
very strange move to my eyes
a very
surprising
uh decision by wesley so queen e4
looks like
like an automatic
yeah gary has played g3 by the way he
and he was very quick so this move c5 is
not a surprise for gary he played it
very quickly g3 is the engine's number
one move in fact so gary quite
comfortable where he is and going for
the big pawn formation guarding his pawn
with f4 exactly bishop g7 yeah black has
to get d6 in at some point or his
position is going to be
busted yeah that's right because not
only will he have a weak pawn on c5 but
gary's pawns will simply raw and we have
we've seen night before now night before
uh
looks like a stutter step from a move
ago i don't like this position
offhand before
um for wesley i mean there are some
little tactical ideas in the position
maybe you could move this bishop back to
b7 and then after bishop g2 and queen g2
there's something happening on uh d3 but
uh of course gary played bishop to d2
and uh
now rook d8 by wesley is still trying to
get this d6 move in at some point and
like coming to d3 sometimes yeah well
knight c3 is an automatic gary has
played it uh gary
is now has ideas like bishop takes b4
knight d5 in mind
um at some point this big
pawn wedge in the middle of the zip
board this pawn on e5 has to be dealt
with and either d6 or f6 is a necessity
so wesley has played the move castles
and now what about your idea of just
taking on before and playing knight d5
i like it
i don't like giving up the bishop right
now i'm thinking that castle's
that knight on b4 is not running away
anywhere gary has a big lead on the
clock by the way look at that he's been
sitting there for about 30 seconds and
still with a lead on the clock so he's
taking this right now as the moment when
all the possibilities that he can
control
he should study and that exchange on b4
unquestionably is on his mind but look
at how quickly his clock is ticking down
after having that full minute on the
clock he's going down now very quickly
to wesley's time intriguing and let me
just critical position indeed i mean big
moment in the game let me just flash
back over to the our other board between
the two
uh america's top two rivals uh fabi anna
black against ikaro nakamura and many
would say the two favorites in this
blitz showdown looks really even steven
to me here um pawn on h5 makes a
strange impression that there it is well
he played an early age four in this
english formation he played in early age
four there was a queen sitting on g6 at
one point and that pawn on h5 chased the
queen away in this position so now the
rook coming over
and it's basically even according to the
engines as well in this position it
looks as though white has lots of space
but at the same time
his isolated pawns
his weak pawn structure may not be
something he wants in the long run and
black looks very solid in this position
right just bishop e7 castles and get out
of dodge
think uh fabi is going to be pleased
with the outcome of this opening how did
gary decide what to play in that
critical position he did as a position
and exploded in that game guys look yeah
go back we go back to this position
right here just a couple of moves and
you see the move a3
well you kind of went quickly there yes
if we can
come to this big board we saw the move
in this position a3 happen for gary
well excuse me it was d5 that happened
in this position and then after a3 the
move d4 and great trades happening in
the middle here the position has
absolutely exploded and after bishop
takes pawn takes and bishop to b2 and
the position has stabilized here with
the two bishops bishop dropping back to
c8 and this is the position we have on
the board right now exactly
castles of course had been played get
the king into safety and f7 f6 a big big
move by wesley has he uh calculated
accurately the consequences of e7 e6
gary gets a pass pawn in the center of
the board the engines are saying that's
a blunder yeah that's a blunder
according to the engines with bishop to
d5 is the move that the engines are
giving bishop to d5 and then an actual
sacrifice of the queen and he had to
sacrifice his rook in that position he
sacrificed an exchange did wesley by
taking on d5 in this position right
because he simply was going to lose
material and he's this is his counter
play chance that he is hoping for and
now
gary up in exchange but he will lose
back the pawn at least after bishop
takes bishop takes i'm not sure i'm not
sure he's going to lose the pawn because
oh he's not there's a queen c4 there's a
trait of queens
queen d takes d5 there's a trait of
queens when necessary by the way
boldly pointing out the obvious the the
rook on a1 is ready to
munch that pawn on a7 this looks lost it
is the engines are saying that this is
busted down a full exchange
in well exchange for a pawn well not
even a pawn it's a full exchange in this
position and never going to get back
real compensation his pawns on the queen
side look awful they're going to drop
like flies and wesley is in a completely
lost position this would be a terrific
start for the former world champion
kasparov that's right so if we if we
play bishop takes e5 well gary can
simply capture with the queen and that's
the big problem if pawn takes we get a
lot of counter play because we're
working out two is yeah is pinned we can
maybe play bishop c4 exactly but no this
is this is lost the engines are giving
this one as done
just no real moves he has taken on e5
queen takes eve and the queen takes
we retort that's right queen takes e5
and then we have to figure out some way
to at least try to win that pawn back on
d5 he's taking some time by the way in
this position is kasparov but queen
takes is the only move to maintain his
advantage actually pawn takes the last
bishop to b7 and problems start with the
counter play on the long dial so gary of
course queen takes being the right move
and he has played it and wesley trying
desperately to get some counter play
with the move rook to e8 that came on
that came really fast well dc thinks we
could play c6 is the engine's first move
d6 with strong mcgary has instead played
rook to d1 not the top move but still
winning but it is bled so we we no i
like this i love winning still winning
no it's not maybe it's just
played another way to try to exchange
squeeze that's the thing a lot of the
tactics we see here are training queens
but losing upon from queen to c4 to d6
to the exact same idea
because then all of your pawns are just
going to drop off the board
so it very thematic ideas here
interesting uh wesley after queen a5
inviting the move rook a1 by gary gary
instead plays rook d2 and gary's idea is
very simple he just basically the rook
on f2 is not working he needs to bring
that rook back to the e file maybe play
a move like h3
uh king g2 h3 but one looks so good
by wesley trying to get a little counter
play on the back rank simply king g2 no
worries
you don't have to worry about the back
rank if your kings on the second round
get true
h3 get that get that bishop out of there
give your king some extra squares and
you know me i love grabbing pawns that
a7 pawn looks delicious
one day but the clock times now guys
the clock times gary though he's up he
hasn't figured out exactly how to win
yet he has played the move h3 bishop
back to f5 now g4 excellent move
excellent we'll get that bishop out of
the way by the way because we would have
probably played queen to d7 to get a
tiny bit of counter play something like
this on h3
you might be working one could be
annoying at some point this
looks harder i mean for an amateur like
playing this and allowing ambition
before it looks uglier but actually
the king is going to be very
very safe and by the way
having booted the bishop two options now
for for white
d5 d6 is in the position so you can play
queen d5 and trade queens as well as f5
and f6 and by the way there's a pass
pawn on the f file whoo
c5 a little queen f6 posting up
and it really looks killing now g6
d6 is going forward is there any
super powerful moves a crushing position
an f5 blasting through what a dominant
performance by kasparov as f5 lands on
the board he's going to open up the
whole king side this is just crushing
epic
checkmate i mean if c3 just takes on g6
should be winning
queen f7 and queen h7 checkmate
it's a force by the way
as they're playing quickly not as sharp
a position right now but caruana is up a
pawn but it's all about this game as
gary is showing his stuff coming out the
gates quickly look at this position 37
checks queen e7 queen takes fa check a
huge threat in the position i think it's
going to be resigns guys i really do
there's nothing to do look at gary grab
the queen
this one will be on the board any second
exactly this is just completely busting
also isn't d8 queens just a threat as
well queen moving over to c5 no i think
queenie seven check is the the the
dominant threat and he's just like queen
d6 queen d6 with all the threats trade
queens and also sacrifice on f8 this is
resignable only 10 seconds left wesley
will probably resign on this move yes
gary gary getting up from the board
firsthand big victory for gary we were
wondering what kind of form is he going
to be in for the splits match well thank
you well jump over to the next board
guys we've got no time to relax because
he caro and fabia are at it and it looks
as though
ikaru got some counter play and now has
a pawn on d7
he's down a pawn but he's looking for
counter play and look at fabi whip out
the move e3 to change the nature of the
game huge move e3 super strong
fabi is playing this beautifully and a
sacrifice and now he's going to play f2
and i mean a check trade excuse me and
then he's going to play f2 forces
looks like he's going to force queen f1
but this rook f4
that could happen any second will he
take the pawn on d well he's giving his
pawn back
no he's had to play queen e7 instead
queen e7 threatening to e3 pawn f2
didn't quite make i think he made some
mark
maurice i think his plan had been f2 all
along miscalculated something came up
with queen e7 instead and 28 seconds
look at the time guy look at the time
rook back and now he played f2
okay what's the big difference now
oh he's got
right well well put well said queen went
to
f5 f5 really so rook f8
sacrifices queen takes f8 queens
exactly rook f8 is a very and he's
played it and he's blundered queen takes
the shotgun
king takes but queen takes now and a
second queen will appear on the board
blunder and he's brought his rook back
now but it's too late queen d8 and d8 is
is it the only move because he'll play
kg2 and take the pawn and the queen will
be stuck on the d8 square temporarily
only nine seconds left for fabi he needs
to hurry up
fighting fighting back how do you win
this position as black
do you what do you do he's starting to
create a pass pawn yeah he's starting to
create a passport there he goes
no he should put his king on e7 create a
pass pawn on the king's side
be able to get deliver queen check so
you can park your king
he's moving back and forth right now
okay look at this he hasn't he has only
five seconds left and he has to play
instantly there goes the pass pawn the
king now curtailing that pawn on that
square and now fabi has to figure out
another plan and here comes the iphone
fighting back is naka that's right
and here we go just three seconds and
now suddenly he's figuring it out he's
figured out a way he's pawning to get a
king and pawn ending but this is not
winning
this is a dre this is
a maximum draw for black i think he
miscalculated
white saxophone and now white is the one
who's winning what a turnaround and
knock us thing ahead on the clock this
is lost horrible this is lost he went
from winning to losing and now fabi has
to resign wow
amazing amazing play by what a save big
turn around there and i think that a lot
of that unfortunately for fabian is that
he's not used to the delay because in an
increment situation that's that's an
easy win easy one for bobby yes but the
delay is the delay kill time
uh this is a critical uh position that
was going on here
uh
let me just as you see the players
recovering from this intense action of
the first game
let me just uh
uh just a second
i the game is being
shown once again as to what happened
miscalculation somebody said it's a draw
but i think that's i think that's a um a
miss no it cannot possibly be a draw
yeah yeah this was this was not a draw
and this is how it all unraveled at the
end
we've got a misprint on the screen right
here
the official results though we are
getting in
um two decisive games here nakamura
defeating fabiano carolina gary caspara
defeating wesley so you know
poor fabi he uh really uh outplayed
nakamura there but then his technique um
you know really needed a little bit of
increment and he made a bad
simplification we've been talking about
simplifications this whole tournament
yes and especially in blitz with just
playing on the delay he wants to make a
simplification but it ended up being a
losing bond end game exactly so let's go
to that critical position guys it was on
move 44
move 44 right here and yes if you could
pull it up on your board i got it uh
move 44 look at fate that was a key move
so let's take a look on your board
after this move rook to f8
nakamura could save himself by actually
queening his pawn if he just queens
right now then he's fine because you
have to leave
with rook takes the queen on d8 and then
check and then he takes the pawn on f2
so that would actually be fine for him
he would be perfectly even in this
position instead in this position
he's thought he was okay with queen
takes f8 only to miss queen takes
and now rook back
hoping again so queen d8 was the mistake
however take a look at what he should
have done he should have queen right now
forcing
the move rook takes queen
and after after this exchange now play
queen d6 getting in front of the pawn
and now d7 drops and the rest would have
been easy
unfortunately he missed that instead he
played the queen to d8 and nakamura
would suddenly king g2 and this made the
game very difficult technically you had
to find moves with the second sticking
down and unfortunately fabi wasn't able
to find the winning plan very easily in
that position but credit is the higher
nakamura because almost everybody would
just go down there to g5 h5 h4 but
nakamura is used to
trying to weasel out of lost positions
and not that he gets him a lot but he
just
wins whether he's losing or winning in
most bullet type situations he's an
extraordinary
resourceful player
is incredible
let's restore our boards here yeah
because we are getting the second round
and of course we're going to start with
this epic match between nakamura and
gary if we thought gary was informed
last game well this will be the real
test against the blitz leg the living
legend versus the blitz light exactly
and the games are underway hikaru white
uh against his co-tournament leader
after a single round we have two winners
playing against each other and the two
players who lost their game are playing
against on purpose that was coincidental
right yes of
of course it was just pretty plain
anyways yeah and we've got
nakamura playing another c4 and then uh
transposing into
perhaps a king's indian defense and look
there we go brewing right now and there
it is a king's indian and hikaru
a big
king's indian defense advocate on the
world elite tour going up against a
player who made a career in the king's
indian and hikaru looking in the air
that's right what variation to test
garrion who's going to make better faces
in this game is my question it's going
to be a close contest
and they're playing the main line
knight c6 is the main line
gary again has made a career in this
defense and look at it
look at this
variation not yet not yet with michigan
1987. no we're still in the classical
main line right now and the 91 line 91
and 92 are the two main lines and 91 was
played 91 knight to d3 and f5 we see
there on the main board
wow and this is this this could be
for 20 moves this is a great theoretical
battle
i i have to remind you of the game that
hikaru nakamura beat wesley
in last year's u.s championship where
hikaru was black that's right that was
and you made it now
c5 changes the strategical direction of
the struggle completely c5 preventing c5
himself and gary is now taking
naca into a different type of territory
with this move c5 not the main move here
and naka hesitated and is captured on c6
which is absolutely not normal either in
this position you saw gary react in that
moment like wait a minute what do you do
what is this about totally taking that's
a natural
you want to just play for b4 and
continue to play on the queen side
because this strengthens black center
absolutely nakamura instead perhaps
trying to play against the weak d6 pawn
but
i mean this is relinquishing control of
the d5 square though exactly certainly
not the typical way of playing and now
gary getting into a deep thing by the
way while they're doing that let's take
a look at the other game just
momentarily fabiano caruana and wesley
so in this position that we see here
much more solid type position in the
game they started knight f3 and and g3
is how fabi started here so we expect
this one to be more of a slow build as
those players are playing on but it's
the other game that we have to pay
attention to that one between kasparov
and nakamura this position is rich man
this kind of position is hard to play
with in over-the-board chess right now
lots of times
and they're gonna have to blitz the
moves out part of me wishes that this
they had 20 minutes on the clock each
year or then we could just see this
opening recur i mean a very unusual
choice for a blitz game yes and for naca
to go into this line as well but look at
gary and now the move c5
c5 giving away the d5 square very
confident but lee played because i
really like this idea uh for black and
the king's indian essentially yes
maurice you're giving up the d5 square
but bobby fisher said to get squares you
got to give them and
and gary has knight c6 knight d4 in mind
that's a great outpost no easy breaks
for white either this is quite critical
no easy breaks for white black looks
like he's done everything right the f5
move is in he can choose how he plays
that side of the board and gary looking
very confident taking this younger
player into strategical nest that he
used to of course dominate the one of
the greatest kings indian players of all
time and before the only main break and
he has found it nakamura said i i've got
to break open this position i cannot
just sit here and let black do what he
wants that's right because now if we
take on c4 um c5 is hanging in the
position and then we start to see
white's pieces leap to life which is
something in the king's indian is so
critical a lot of times white's piece is
not that great but if you can release
the energy in them they just look
beautiful that was the best move in the
position and that's my car engine
approved you need brakes without them
you cannot build your position and gary
realizes it naca also realizes and look
and he has taken on c4 as kasparov
bravely opening the position and bc5 now
on the board that's right instantly bc5
because it's the only way to get your
pawn back exactly but now
now it's amazing you know finding this
move b4 and not allowing knight c6 it
was his last chance it was now or never
and looks nakamura he found it rook c8
got by the way the number one move by
the engine sacrificing potentially the
a7 pawn but he did it look how quickly
gary played the move that's the number
one computer move how these guys are
playing the best moves by engine choice
in blitz is simply incredible how good
they are that they could beat most
people on the planet with only two
minutes on the clock even if you had two
days you couldn't keep up and now sea
takes yeah yeah
he's very offended that you said that
he'd say he'd give me 20 seconds man
after
d6 so what does happen after well we
don't have time to analyze
quickly declined upon offer instead
played the move knight c5 offering a
trade of queens which indeed has
happened so the the fires in the
position are a little bit dying down as
these pieces get traded but there is a
trick for
check this out you uh take on e2 knight
takes e2 take on e4 if you take with the
pawn knight g4 is going to be very very
annoying i can insert 96. that is true
that's an important uh point you're
making jen
but it did happen
it did happen
you've got time for takes on f3 yeah
yeah doesn't want to see any of that
position so he's played
right well now after knight takes e4
knight f5 hitting the bishop on uh
e3 is a kind of an automatic move in
these positions but he has to be careful
though because the a7 pawn is soon going
to hang and i like the way knock is
handling this he's playing control chess
forcing gary to play technical moves on
every single move making sure that
there's nothing that gary could like he
started with a king's indian that
possibly could be very aggressive with
attacks but now there are no attacks in
the position for black he has to defend
the slightly worse end game
but an absolutely brilliantly played
game by both players so far for blitz
games
absolutely this isn't this could have
been moving
this is an extraordinary standard
of play i mean i'm a blitz player i love
playing blitz but these guys are playing
on an extr and a really high level i
will tell you they've been playing the
number one or two computer move every
single move they are playing amazing
this could be a world championship match
game right here how well they are
playing this well the move dc60 just
took it into a different direction than
naka but everything and now the trade on
c1 rook takes a very long think a very
carefully executed trade i don't think
gary
is
pleased with the outcome of from the
opening that the position he has but he
played great
he's got to get counter play here so
he's played the move now you don't need
to d5 he needs to get some energy for
those pieces but i'll tell you he's
offering pawn on a7 and it's good it's a
good offer he's he's not going to be
much worse off because of this trade on
a seven according to the how are you
going to keep the [ __ ] of an advantage
for white in that line how do you go
bishop a7 rook a8 bishop f2 because
you're back two why can't we take any
what's
we have knight g8 right so i mean yeah
not pretty but i mean i get my pawn back
nakamura is stopping to think now is
that no good bishop a7
rook a8 bishop f2 rook takes a to rook
cajac knight g8 right and then i got a
an issue so i'll go knight g3
he just played bishop f2 there were no
there bishop takes on a7 did not lead
anywhere attract actually you didn't
have to take immediately on uh you
didn't have to play you could just take
on e4 and tie him down to the e pawn and
gary now
whoa didn't he let go
he did let go um i think he did i think
he did he let go that allows the move
bishop
no but it's touch
it it's not it's touch move clearly but
it's not touch release
but did he let it go yes
but in blitz you're allowed it's touch
clock
so long as you move the uh
move but did he play no he's played nice
you see the the board the dgt boards
guys have recorded the move night before
and there's going to be an issue now i'm
afraid yeah because we're going to have
to do that
exactly before we lose to bishop c5
correct if you try knight d3 we have
bishop takes off eight knight takes in
one bishop well no the keyboard is
updated
oh you're right
it's auto corrected auto corrected
brilliant i was afraid that it was going
to go into her friend that moment you're
saying when you play night before and
let go you you're allowed to let go
you're allowed to let go it's when you
press your clock your turn is done and
when
when is this rule come into effect i
thought it wasn't when you let go it's
the move is over no and classical chess
absolutely
yeah and i'm i'm quite certain you let
go
we'll we'll do a real play at the end of
those rules what's happening when we're
done
the other game the other game right now
well caruana is completely winning and
we will go to jump to that critical
moment in this game because not because
he has dominance right now in the
position does caruana according to the
engines if he finds the simple move
bishop to d2 guarding his pawn then he
will win the game he's instead played
somewhat differently in that position
but let's get back to the other ending
we'll recap that one when we get to it
okay
and the players
are in a rook and bishop versus rook and
bishop
um
[Music]
and caruana did win his game so he is
through with a win against wesley so
getting the point let's get to this
position though on the board as they are
blitzing down what about that bishop
takes a7
and he's played it he's taken and
defended the bishop with rook
c7
rook came to e8 rook dropped back to
protect the 8-ball now
the rook will go back to attack the
bishop i don't think
nakamura wants anything to do with rook
a4 allowing a pin so he's repeated and
now but now gary plays rookie eight
which is exactly what has happened jen
and a draw
well he's just saying you can have the
e-pawn if you go after we if you start
pushing with a4 but now rook to c6
hitting the g6 pawn and he's decided to
just grab and now rook to a4 and that's
going to be the a pawn and black should
be perfectly fine after rook takes on
a2 he might lose his h-pawn he's
checking that out
he doesn't want to lose his h-pawn that
that is going to happen and he's
patiently deciding no i'm not giving you
the pawn with that last move move the
king out of there eight the rook out of
there now i can take and he has and
now after the f pawn but it doesn't look
as though this will be enough to win
even if he trades rooks in this position
here comes the king and now chasing the
rook out of there and challenging him to
find a way to get an advantage but he's
starting he's keeping moving nakamura
down to 19 seconds when did that happen
boy you got to keep the track eye on the
clock don't you i mean it just sneaks up
on you bishop f6 looks like a very
decent move and gary has made that and
i'm sure the players are going to offer
a draw
now
frozen at 19 because of the three second
delay so as long as he moves quickly
there should be no win here at all they
should be a draw being agreed to any
second exactly gary looking around
seeing whether or not he can make some
kind of hay attacking the bishop on e1
looks like he's trying to get back door
and play the move rook to f8 at some
point he knows he has a time edge on the
clock right but now he's backed up to
rook c4 yeah and the thing is now the
bishop on f6 attacking h4 creating a
balance in the position
exactly
wait a minute wait a minute the bishop
can go to e4 well they've it's great it
is it's time for a draw they're out of
there bro so actually an arrow escaped
by gary in a way because he almost
played that midnight before which would
have been a terrible wonder
absolutely jen you said you asked what
kind of forum gary kasparov is in the
big test
that's right we just got an answer
a wonderful game there by both players
uh beautiful to watch we got nakamura
and gary kasparov they both have one and
a half fabiano carrana
still in it he's won against wesley so
wesley
we're gonna have to see if he gets into
better blitz form in this tournament and
maurice has the highlight from the
yes they had this quiet position quiet
looking at least on the board black with
the bishop on d4 white having the two
bishop edge and the question was what to
do here well caruana went for it in this
moment and played the move g4 you go
from one quiet position to something
that just simply explodes the threat of
g5 just about unstoppable he moved his
king not necessarily the best choice but
what was he to do takes takes and now
this night passive was ever back here
the move bishop takes on f7 and that was
all she wrote in this position because
of the queen h5 problem
if knight takes queen check knight back
bishop here and that would have been all
she wrote so in this position after this
the knight having to drop back bishop
seven just as critical pawn down he
played queen e7 he kept his pawn with
this move and after check just relaxing
and then this move queen h3 check knight
h5 queen to c8 bam mate in one coming
you have to throw your queen in the way
and that was it so that is how he won
that game fabiano bravely going forward
with the move g4 finding just the right
time to increase the advantage in the
position and now he has one point an
extremely well played game between gary
kasparov and
hikaru nakamura we reached this critical
moment on my board when gary played the
move knight f4
prior to playing this move he had
actually put the knight on b4 and did he
release the uh did he release it let's
take a look indeed let's take a look and
note that
and here we go right
but he did not
he really released it without the
questions
but he almost hit the clock even and
that rewind here we go once again
he
almost hit the clock
look at look at look at this hey karu's
face right there he's laughing yeah he's
so sheepish i think he's saying like
saying man if he's gonna play a move
like night before i am gonna win this
match even if i don't win this game
okay and gary
and players are back at the board and of
course knight b4 would have been a
disastrous blunder instead nakamura just
got a small in-game edge and um gary
defended well and scored the draw but
here we have him up again he's playing
against fabiano caruana our u.s chess
champion
this is a big game and he's he's
repeating his stats from round one
especially since
gabby the u.s champion just defeated
wesley so
and is now at 50 percent
gary plus one along with the carl and
nakamura and it's the scotch but we see
a little bit of a twist so instead of
wesley's bishop a6 we have a knight
beast the knight v6 line on the board
instead of the second main line
bishop a6 has long been the main line
knight b6 is a very good
uh option as well
uh
and in the other game
and wesley are playing a nimzo indian
very classic position there so no big
deal for now they're just still in the
opening
as they continue their game
let me switch the board there yes i see
what you're saying yeah just a standard
position and wesley has taken off the
jacket i told him
it was time to pull up the sleeves a
little bit as well no need for a jacket
when you're playing blitz but he's going
up against a guy who actually crushed
him in a death match on chess.com where
he just got dominated by hikaru did
wesley so he better start winning some
games to save some ego he's already lost
two games in the competition exactly i i
really think short sleeves if you're
going to play a long blitz match don't
do it in long sleeves
gary didn't get that memo
yeah not the
well gary's got his dress shirt but not
the overcoat either and gary kasparov
and fabiana cariwanna are playing a main
line theory in a scotch defense
it uh this
position had occurred in one of gary's
world championship matches and maurice
what could be better
than that to have analysis that you used
in a world championship match before
fappy was born what's incredible is that
you're seeing this kind of theory in
blitz normally players will avoid the
theory play some kg moves b3 even will
show up but these guys are going down
main line gary kasparov a very
principled player you could have
expected that he's not going to run away
from the theoretical battles he
unquestionably
decided to study all the lines patch up
some lines for sure but you know every
game of gary's is going to be some
principal variation that's the way he
conducted his entire career and it
doesn't matter if he's playing blitz
exactly and he's castle queenside as
well and i think it's a strategy also
every single blitz game he's played has
been extraordinarily rich king's indian
defense the scotch and that's his main
lines
that's the way he plays that's the way
he plays he's just not going to duck
those lines he's prepared for this he's
ready to play into the good stuff not he
doesn't play bogus lines he never won
his world channel title by playing bogus
lines absolutely that's the way he rolls
and we just saw this move c5 opening up
this bishop on on b7 that was obscured
by the pawn on c6 making it awkward for
his opponent to develop this bishop on
f1 just before the move castles i had
actually expected gary to play the move
g3 in anticipation of bringing the
bishop g2 that did not happen and on
this board i should point out he just
played h4 on the other board the move h4
was played but with more evil intent it
might be positional here but in this
game wesley so has played the move h4 to
go after the king the move h5 coming
soon daring naka to take this pawn on h4
and nakamura stopping to think right now
should he take the pawn or just play
rook to c8 the ninjas are saying don't
take the pawn play the move rook to c8
right now but daca now thinking about it
for quite some time right now in this
position it's surprising he's taking so
long we should take a look at his board
to see why it is that he's he's studying
the position he actually decided you
know what he took the long think give me
the pawn
go attack me i dare you
well i don't think wesley played h4
thinking that this pawn was was going to
be taken there's a there's a beautiful
tactical motif in the position after d5
takes bishop h6 now your rook is trapped
don't you dare move your rook because
that bishop that bit that little pawn
bait over on h4 that could cost you so
bishop h6 and d5 yes and bishop 86 the
engines are saying after bishop 86 you
will have to sacrifice that exchange
will wesley just go right for it bishop
h6 forces the sacrifice of the exchange
and he's traded only
five first well he's traded often he
didn't have to play d5 first he could
have just played it right away but now
he's traded off and just going for a
traditional attack based on dark
square's
looks promising idea
okay i've got to get an auto
that came very interesting and nakamura
pulling his knight back to defend
um sorry
yes he pulled his knight back to e7 to
try to defend you know we we presume
that uh wesley is trying to play rook h3
you know he's played rook g3 and he said
threatening
the engines love that one the queen is
about to be five
beautiful and yeah queen's in trouble in
that square how does he save himself
that's right there's queen h5 and bishop
d1
d1 is a killer
knock more in trouble
nice one nakamura in trouble right now
after that beautiful move rook to g3
what's he going to come up with in this
position
wow
yikes this is not what we expected and
this is why we gotta love the blitz i
i'm no big fan of and ready to sacrifice
the queen with knight f5 there's got to
be a queen side whoa yes he's played
queen h5 bishop d1 instantly played naka
saw this coming and there's the
sacrifice taking a roll
bishop takes h5 and then knight takes
and he played queen takes he played
queen takes and the game is over the
game is over queen
wesley fans are cheering about that one
game we saw h4 the maneuver rook h3 rook
e3 and then e5 bro e5 was attacked rook
to e3
nice maneuver with this idea h4 looked
like you want to play h5 by the way the
the white pawn on h4 is hanging
at the moment so this
bishop takes e5 but it's not hanging
because if you take on h4 i take on g7
and i've got the rook protected that's
right so if you go bishop takes e5 rook
takes e5 your rook on e8 is hanging so
you can't take on h4 right away
but that is in the position no question
about it maurice looks like
f6 might be f6 bishop d4
bishop here's the here's the cherry
sharp here's the challenge i mean he can
also he could also take on e5 rook takes
and drop his queen back and guard the
rook on e8 and then he will be fine in
that position the biggest one
the biggest problem for black let's just
from positional features is that knight
on b6
that knight has to get back into the
game at some point
black's king side is compromised that is
where the black king is i mean is the
castle position is compromised so white
just needs to steady this position to
feel comfortable in a blitz game
especially if i can just steady this
position maybe get his knight into the
game somewhere strong then black will
have to figure out what to do about that
knight on b6
so right now fabi spending a long time
he just dipped below kasparov just like
that while i was talking
that's right he's got to make a move
good night
bishop here if he tries bishop h6 here
it is bishop d4
bishop h6
uh idea of putting some pressure on this
f-pawn i think a 4-point i think i'd
just drop back with my bishop instead he
played f6 indeed in bishop d4 and we
have that on the board right now i see
so f6
this is a good line as well the move f6
bishop back
to d4 is a good line the engine is
saying you can sacrifice the pawn on c5
this right this position right here so
did he play queen f7 he did very quickly
played queen to f7 what's up on maurice
it's just c5 yes but it's just the pawn
according to engine because of the move
f5
f5 releasing that bishop on the long
diagonal with a queen about to appear on
f6 this is a real challenge right here
to
the position there are lots of tactical
tricks so gaspara of now thinking and
now his time almost dropped and f5 was
taking the pawn knight to f3 so knight
f3 so that uh we can stick a knight on
e5 against your queen f6 idea your evil
idea
but this position is is just about equal
according to the engines bishop to e4
being a strong move right now putting
that bishop right on e4 but guys the
clock look at the clock 111 and counting
down for fabiano gary with 115. this is
going to turn crazy in a second
as fabi is going down under a minute as
of right now and he's finally playing
bishop to d5 bishop to e4 that's right
that was a huge moment though he had to
take the time that's right because he
might have been calculating bishop f3
and queen s6 but at the point things
always stick themselves on e5 they're
still like a rookie five right and you
can even like sacrifice that sometimes
because you you're threatening bishop e6
and queen eight ideas of your own 100 on
the on the button i would uh pop the
knight into e5 or player rook takes d8
first there's something to be said about
tossing in this move rook takes d8 to
ask black how he wants to recapture
we've got 95 bishop e5 pawn e5 on the
board right gary didn't go for that line
that i just mentioned and the training
is allowed brook takes d1
and rook d8 anyway
strange
maneuvers
does
fabi have enough compensation for the
pawn well opposite
well two bishops against the yeah this
is actually a very strange position
queen e1 queen e5 threatening the idea
of queen a5 correct those those are
typical motifs in the sky pawn though
the e5 it's still on the board
definitely a pawn that you can't protect
he can attack it maybe with queen e6
that's a move for fobby but he has to
hurry up giddy up 32 seconds and
counting down is he aware of the clock
at all and he has played the ball but
he's playing
instantly played by the way instantly
played by gary gary
no hesitation about defending the e5
pawn whatsoever and queen to c6
attacking the bishop
and it's gary's turn now as his bishop
is hanging what to do he doesn't want to
trade down by playing bishop takes b6 uh
bishop e7 bishop f6 makes a lot of sense
positions of b4 there should be four
i thought he was going to play bishop b2
bishop a3 i'm sorry and whoa he's taking
on jesus
i don't like feel right
but the english are saying it's still
within the boundaries of acceptability
right now bishop g2 and gary though
flustered seeing his pawn go off the
board needing a move and he has dropped
low on time and he's going to have to
play quickly look at that
gallop down the board and he was
surprised but bobby was some counter
play immediately it was a move at four
no question about it gary's got to
change his
his top his tempo right now and whoa
he's sacrificing his rook for the rook
on d8 17 seconds for gary kasparov 22
seconds to for fabiano
you let down to 11. look at the clock
you can see it on the webcam
leaving the board now gary just and he
had to promote come on it took him a
second or two to get that guy
because you've got to make the queen
you've got to put the queen on the
illegal move otherwise and queen takes
e3 has been played
massive and queen takes a2
oh my goodness gary's
king is more vulnerable than fabiano
bishop
jack
mating ideas for gary fabiano may be
forced to take but now we have this as
we see
we have we have bishop c3 in between
what was bishop c3 c3
bishop g5
and now gary just whipping off a pawn
he's now up and they're blitzing on the
moves looks like it should be some kind
of a pet here's the knight showing up to
help defend it's hard to believe he'll
lose his position but bobby with only a
few seconds on his clock he's got to
hurry up the king taking the pawn and
now the knight trapping the king over
there
and gary now trading queens quickly and
the pawn dropping and this game is drawn
they've agreed to a draw
amazing oh look amazing look at the
sense of relief man i'm too old for this
these guys young guys look at his eyes
they were wide open like do you believe
what i just did that was amazing i'm the
perfect age for this let's see did
bishop c3 win you were going over a line
i
who knows i'm catching my breath
jennifer you're asking me a question
like that after queen's e7
you have queen d7 and king c8 well it's
not that clear maybe maybe bishop c3 was
a stronger choice hold on but i didn't
see queen seven so i thought it won
instantly but yeah queen d7 the idea i
think it would have
basically transposed into something
similar to the game exactly yeah it did
not win according to the engine okay
is the only player coming out of that
round undefeated the only player
so we could see the results of that
particular round and it is gary kasparov
leading after the first round two points
of a win in two draws followed by
fabiano caruana and hikaru nakamura at
one and a half and wesley soh winning
his game very nicely with a tactical
trick against ikaru nakamura
who would have thought
that gary kasparov coming out of still
in retirement excuse me which is coming
out to play some exhibition chances
and showing that he is the man and well
it's only one round but still
very impressive play so far um very
impressive but i i gotta i gotta still
be nakamura
because i feel like he he lost that game
to seoul but otherwise he's been looking
really hot in this blitz well maurice
asked a question who would have thought
i'll tell you a secret between ourselves
we have a side bet i put 10 bucks on
um
on gary and gave him the field but he
has to give me 15 dollars in case
i win the bet whoa high stakes chess yes
you guys you bet
baby gary makes you look good right now
yeah indeed i need a little extra but we
are gonna take a quick break as we get
ready for round two if it's anything
like round one you better stay tuned and
keep your heart rate down exactly we'll
be back in about 10.
[Music]
i have to say this has been the most
exciting
the most eventful
and uh certainly one of the most
spectacular
series of championships that we've ever
run
if somebody would have told me eight
years ago that we were going to be
hosting the u.s chess championships here
in st louis for eight years in a row it
would have been hard to believe
the winner this year of the u.s women's
championship please welcome nazi piketsi
[Music]
the new champion of the united states
championship grand master fabiano
caruana
we can't just have a u.s championship or
a u.s women's championship we have to do
more the top three finishers from the
championship along with grand master
kasparov will play a series of round
robin blitz tournaments against each
other we are in for a very exciting
event
[Music]
you could fly to venice
or paris
or even copenhagen
you could fly all over the world
but why
when you could just come
to st louis
your trip begins at explorestlouis.com
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to ultimate blitz
here in st louis in our first round we
saw some really sizzling games big
highlight was gary kasparov and hikaru
nakamura's epic struggle in the king's
indian defense which ended up in a draw
but let's take a look at the full
standings from round one well gary
kasparov he's actually meeting with two
points that's huge news as we wondered
what kind of form he would be in going
into this nakamura and carolina half a
point behind they've got one and a half
each and wesley so losing two in a row
but coming back with a beautiful quickie
over nakamura and i think nakamura next
time against wesley he's gonna go for a
slower game no question but mr decisive
wesley so with uh three decisive games
that there was big news i confirmed with
tony rich international arbiter
maurice was right i was wrong gary
kasparov releasing the piece
releasing his knight on b4 determines
his move and hikaru nakamura could have
insisted that gary kasparov
play that losing move he did not and the
moment passed that's right
it was a great game so hicaro showing
his
gentleman side by allowing that to
happen and gary maybe not certain about
that rule as you were not either
and we've got a we've got some games
going on now gary kasparov playing a
mainline groom vote against wesley i'm
sorry to say i don't have uh the games
on my screen
uh my my board is not being updated at
the moment so i'm sorry i can't show the
uh
we do have the overhead view here
we'll get the
2d graphic up in a second but my board
is not showing that we could come to
this board the big board showing got it
showing both as well we have two
positions if you look you see wesley
here playing gary gary just played the
move queen to d7 fabiano against
nakamura as you can take a look at both
boards simultaneously and it looks as
though clock times kasparov has again
not used any time on the clock
five minutes on his [ __ ] while wesley
seeing this move queen d7 has been
thinking for some time he's at 419 and
on the other side they're in a very
quiet position right now absolutely and
gary kasparov essaying
uh one of his favorite mainstay defenses
the grunfeld jennifer you love to play
the groomfeld very sharp consequential
play and so does wesley so
the groomfeld popular
for a number of players with the black
pieces but
this game wesley with white has just
played this move h4 h4 so he's been
playing he did he played it with success
against um nakamura so why not just keep
going for those king side attacks now
with the move queen a4
attacking the pawn on a2
because that will also lead to a double
attack against the bishop money two and
the work on v1 exactly right so wesley
so pursuing his attack is sacrificed
upon with the move h5 challenging
gary kasparov to capture uh this pawn on
a2
will he get his hands stuck in the
cookie jar like hikaru nakamura did
where he caro grabbed upon that maybe he
shouldn't have well queen chu is another
option you know but i guess we always
have you always have work to be too and
he's taking the part in a2
is
legal according to the computer
the computer is saying look you could
take the pawn
and still get away with it white will
end up having a slight edge in this
position now the queen dropping back and
wesley pursuing his aim of attacking on
that king side
down upon for the moment but what can he
drum up he doesn't look as though he can
repurpose his forces to that side very
easily now trading on a6
white has to be just
white's a a bit happy that he's got the
center but he's got to be careful that
his pawn advan pawn disadvantage doesn't
start to tell in this game as at the
moment he is down upon typical grinfo
sacrifice but is it enough
i guess knight g5 in queen h3 is the uh
definitely definitely the main idea by
the way sometimes uh the club works
intermezzo taking on d4 first kasparov
trying to tie down
the piece to the d4 pawn
it's not only that it's because he gets
two connected past pawns maurice right
so now so it's all or nothing
white has to check mate gary's king he
will lose an end game unless he lands a
fatal blow on the king's side now the
engine is giving the move queen did he
play queen e2 he did threatening rook a2
um and
um that that's a big threat to starting
to win a piece so it looks like gary is
going to have to move tonight
yeah
knight before it seems like the most
logical and uh
by the way the moving that knight does
release the a-pawn he's getting ready to
push queenie so queen c48
was not his best move don't like the
move with queenie
is not what the position was about the
engines wanted him to shift and go to
the king's side where his attack was
queen f4 mcqueen e2 knight c7 now on the
board 1967 oh he didn't stop that one on
the board and the engines think that is
not enough compensation for white here
after knight c7 and it looks as though
wesley has almost given up on that king
side attack and is is now
attacking on the queen side surprisingly
so like he's feeling like he's down a
pawn and every move he makes with the
attitude that he's down upon is making
it a reality
as he tries to attack on a queen side
where he simply didn't belong and he
wasn't called for he is now slowly going
down to being to actually being down an
actual pawn and look at that he's back
on e3 so that shows that all those moves
were pointless essentially that he
played and gary's aware of it those uh
tempe are so crucial in in
games like this where the attack has to
come on the king side to justify the
pawn gambit and
wesley's
stutter step is not helping his cause
whatsoever i
clearly i don't like what wesley did on
his last few moves nobody does and now
gary has to figure out exactly how to
prosecute this pawn advantage he's not
put his queen on c4 challenging the rook
he doesn't want the rooks to double on
the a line for sure so just
testing this rook what square will it go
to and that work has to go back toward
the middle of the board and it really
shows how badly white played this
position and by the way i really like
this movement queen c4 a lot it's
preparing the move knight e6 which has
the double duty of protecting against
knight g5 as well as simultaneously
hitting this pawn on d4 the knight
coming to e6 will be a useful defender
as well as an aggressive force against
the pawn on d4 and rook to d2 by wesley
giving up all the demonstrations he had
it looked like he lost maybe two or
three moves in his last couple of moves
putting his rook from b2 to d2 only as
his queen was on e3 before meantime
kasparov has consolidated on the queen
side the problem is he's taking too long
to figure out his advantage he is now at
138 and counting down while wesley is at
3 11. we have not seen this disparity in
any of the games and kasparov now
nervous bouncing back and forth and
wesley as cool as a cucumber right there
trying not to move hoping that gary
continues to think
121 and counting down gary needs a move
that's right well gary wants to try to
create a play on that uh d-pawn but he's
just worried about this bay 31
a little bit indecisive uh decision
making there by gary as he
really goes down to two minutes on the
clock and it says move bishop a3 has
been played
rook
waste the time that last few moves a
total waste of time and now kasparov
despite being up upon is now in a bit of
trouble he's playing the move knight to
b5 and actually he's found a great move
knight to b5 that one attacking the pawn
on on d2 the engines did not like by the
way the move bishop to a3 precisely
because of this response gary has found
it but a minute and three seconds left
will he be able to giddy up so that he
can really prove himself here wesley's
forced to play e5 apparently bishop b2
he's actually played back so the idea
there is that after bishop e7 you just
have rick d7 yes and then next move you
take on d4 and precisely all your pieces
are flooding into the game so tricky to
see in great form today what's going on
gary's 53 seconds
wesley is way
way ahead on the clock and he is
defending
admirably in this position and now the
knight has left into c3
whoa what's going on guys what's going
on gary kasparov just put his knight in
a an obvious pin and he's dead an
obvious pin look to see one and he
[Music]
and his time is ticking down it's it's
over it is over he's going to lose a
piece i wonder if he hallucinated 92. of
course 32 queen tijuana or something i
don't know some kind of weird
hallucination
that that rooksy one was for some reason
being answered by 92
he just forgot that the bishop there it
is resignation
okay this is going to happen i i will
predict that there will be a horrifying
blunder by each and every player in this
event and we just saw one bite let's
take a look at the other game though
where
nakamura is in deep trouble against
caruana as wesley so picks up another
point two in a row for him nakamura
being dominated by white's pieces in
this game complete spatial control by
caruana and ahead on the clock as well
let's just add that that he's down upon
on top of all of that looks like well no
no he's not down upon yet my apologies
he's still just down space and he's
playing the move queen to h5 to stop the
threat of knight takes e6 i know what
you're saying about that spatial
domination but in blitz chess it's the
material you want to have a material
domination not just an advantage of uh
the space
uh nice play though i have to say
kg check this out move rook f4 is
setting up for a g4 and he played eight
six and g4 is in the position g4 is a
strong move and then we can play queen h
we can't play queen h4 because knight f3
or something precisely yeah g4 is a big
move you see him in looking over on that
side of the board he wants to play it
and he's playing it and he has played it
now nakamura's walk right into this fork
of the pawn absolutely another another
time his queen on h5 he just lost his
queen on h5 to wesley so and now his
queen on h5 causing him trouble and he's
taken on h4 knight f3 is just crushing
and has been played and that's knight f3
on the board to h3
and take that knight give me your night
baby
that's right this is uh this is nakamura
getting into trouble with his queen
right funny position
oh my goodness
but look at fabi's time he's got to make
a move 50 seconds and ticking down he's
not confidently grabbing this knight on
the f5 square 91 is another move as well
maybe he's looking at this technically
but finally he has taken what would have
been a very natural move another move g5
in the sacrifice he had calculated this
sacrifice in the position
oh my goodness it's a crushing line he
found this sequence a crushing line and
now naka in trouble but can he perform
the trickery he did in game one to come
back and save himself that's going to be
the big question right now the
resourceful economy why is this so great
if you can
just play rook three four no we play f6
oh he's playing
and that dominating pawn yeah yeah yeah
and then this jeep on is going to be
weak he'll he'll slide his rook over to
g4
and uh brilliant brilliant f6 is a great
in-between mode oh
after we take an f1 not only do we win
the rook back but we also get the
beautiful four
seven on the board rook g7 on the board
and it has been played the line whoa
what has been played
rook g7 f6 and rook g5 was played in the
game and fabian update and let's get
back to this game rook takes king moves
over to f1 and we have this position oh
big move a5 securing that
delicious outpost on c5 positional
masterpiece right now master class
look at this mission but fi and five you
also had on the clock making life easier
as he's just completely dominating this
position strategic masterpiece going on
here and he's ripped off the pawn on a6
brought his knight back now naka's only
hope is the h pawn will it go anywhere
but there goes an a6 pawn galloping down
the board as the rook has come over
trying to trade itself in the game i
don't see the defense whatsoever
uh maurice look at that
rook a1 now the rook has to go over and
stop that and there it is
nakamura whoa
the leader board is shaking up
after that last round everybody winning
everybody losing
yeah
i think i think we're all like even now
because wesley's got to wesley came back
with that huge victory over the
tournament he must be leading now
and we're going to look at gary's face
when you realize this huge blunder in a
beautifully played oh
oh there we go
that was a mike tyson wake up
you could not believe he had such a
winning position
well let's look at our scoreboard indeed
fabiano carrana now leading by half a
point
and gary kasparov and wesley so half a
point behind and it's actually nakamura
in many people's eyes the pre-tournament
favorite who's half a point behind but
hey sellers those fourth place but those
scores are so bunched up of course so
bonsai just started come on how much
more chess do we have to play today oh
my goodness 18 games
total of 18 games today and then another
18 tomorrow yeah no no no
tomorrow night each player plays nine
games yeah correct and it's two two two
players right so it's
18 games total a
tomorrow so we've got lots of chess to
go i expect to see them jumping
flip-flopping over each other like
dolphins in this one as the leaders will
fade and players were in the cellar will
rise absolutely incredible so far the
way they're playing chess this is the
good stuff blitz chess it's too bad
there's no trash talking going on at the
same time as well but we have fun
watching this and and again this matchup
another versus kasparov
it's just fun looking at their faces
one and a half out of four not his best
blitz day he got his queen trapped twice
same thing he's safe
really really shocked he walked into
that g3 g4 uppercut there by fabiano and
our leader starting with wesley so who's
on his own street with two wins back to
back
yeah don't count him out we were you're
counting them out hey
two losses
jacket and by the way uh another
basically
um
gary is saying hey if you play e5
against me we ain't playing berlin's
we're playing scotch but uh nakamura the
first to do something a little different
and play the line with fish yeah play
the line with bishop c5 instead of the
um
knight c6 line that's how gary is he's
so principled they'll say yes you can
aim at me all you want well first of all
how are you going to react in the one
day we're playing right now so he
decided to go right into a line that he
prepared for a world championship match
and he said prove it prove it i'm going
to come in with a few wrinkles prove
that you can equalize against me and
look at this he's getting an edge on the
clock at the very beginning just about
every game
and by the way again i mean gary retired
in 2005 that he's still showing that his
world championship match experience and
his preparation he believes in it well
he's also very involved in chess don't
forget about the rising stars program
where he works with all the talented
players in america the most talented
young players partnering with the saint
louis chess club so he's keeping sharp
yeah but teaching and playing are two
different things as you very well know i
mean you do lose your edge when you you
when you go into coaching motif well i
don't think he's coming to this match
gold i think he's had some blitz split
snacks he's been he's training he told
me he lost weight he's really looking
for he was looking forward to this
exhibition match for quite some time by
the way both of these players lost the
last round and have to clear their heads
somebody could lose again and go two
down in a row so they definitely are
trying to get their brains fresh and
that's hard to do every round when you
only have a couple of minutes to do so
after a tough loss well gary's been
known to do that and by the way i just
want to sorry quickly point out there is
a trap i'm not sure if i know it very
well there is a trap that if you go
knight g4 there's some ideas of knight
b5 and knight c7 but
there's bishop you know what i'm saying
there's like a double yeah there's a lot
of trickies so just keep that in mind
that those that here we could probably
yeah that knight g4 and hikaru
taking some time and has played knight
g4 so he's basically saying
i'm going to take this bishop if you're
not careful
and from
gary's point of view gary doesn't want
to necessarily retreat the bishop would
love to trade it i'm just looking at
this move knight uh v5 for a second what
am i missing so if we play knight you
got to play bishop takes e3 right right
so if we play bishop e3 and you play
knight c7
oh you were going to play pawn takes you
guys
no i was just going to say
and if i recapture there's this
unfortunate move queen e5 with the
double threat you got checkmate down
here
guys i'm stunned you were able to do all
that analysis and gary hasn't
it's moved blitz game it's right out of
the opening and he spends all that time
giving nakamura a time edge which is not
something you want to do in what is just
simply a basic opening position and
kasparov
it's hard to believe he's taking this
much time if we could switch over to the
other game just for a quick second we
have pretty much a
boring position on the board but that
could explode at any moment right here
between caruana and wesley so we see
wesley developing this game but the game
is so blocked that it's going to take a
mistake on a real mistake on either
player's part as they're keeping the
time situation balanced as well so this
game not that interesting just yet we'll
jump back to it let's get back to our
featured game whoa i said that and
suddenly he played the move g5
g5 on the board in the other game
g5 and change the nature of the position
totally
whoa that's a move he's trying to get
that queen away from the bishop so he
can trade for it and force a pawn on the
e5 square right and then maybe playing a
c4 or something there's a knight c4 shot
too maurice that's important you do if
you put your queen back on e3 or the d2
retreat square squares knight c4 is
automatic i think he's going to have to
go for queen g4 and the question is will
this move e5
be a
potentially a liability uh for black
students he played queen back to f3 and
the engines are definitely liking takes
on e5 and then after queen f3 take it on
e5 and play knight c4 and it's black
with the initiative in that position
by the way threats like d4 coming this
is looking good for fabiano that move g5
really a great moment to play that move
but he has to find this continuation
bishop takes and allow his king side to
be porous more porous will it be worth
it exactly and let's go back to the
other game because uh
i i'm really curious to see how did he
handle knight g4 by the way bishop e3
knight never happened he just oh he
never happened he just castle castled
and he allowed white to have a very
powerful pawn on e4 now
and i do like gary kasparov's position
yeah but gary's playing so slowly he's
only had two minutes
you know and his time is ticking even
faster than that actually
he's got a minute that's right he's at
206 on the clock nakamura with lots of
time they're just in the opening why did
he spend so long he's gonna have to play
a whole middle game potentially an
entire end game and defeat nakamura that
that use of the clock was not great for
him he did not play nice c2 he played
queen d2 in that position queen to d2
has been played and definitely time
mismanagement on the part of gary caspar
of maurice yes definitely and in the
meantime naca again looking at that
queen on the king side is this queen
going to end up trapped on h5 again that
queen is
all it takes these journeys dr moore's
queen sitting on f6 the threat of bishop
to g5 is not a pure threat right now in
the position surprising that naca
himself is deep in thought here
they're playing like
they got all day you're not sitting in
the forest park right now guys you've
got to make moves this is blitz chess
and these two players still haven't
found their form
agreed just yeah agreed what that is
their blitz form nakamura's been playing
bullet like for the last 36 hours
straight is what i've heard and guess
what this is not one minute chess this
is five plus five with three second
delay that's a totally different animal
and there we go knight a5 that i was
gonna say this bishop on b3 is just far
too annoying
uh gotta go gotta go problem is if you
try to preserve it with a move like
bishop g2 then we get knight c4 into the
game knight b5 on the board ignoring the
threat knight b5
looking at that c7 pawn
strategical point here leaving the
position just as is and this this is
just too interesting on move 14 i'm
sorry they've used more than half their
time and it's only moved 14 in the game
way too much time and even naca the last
two moves how did he lose his minute and
a half time advantage he's now under the
clock under gary's clock this is totally
absurd this is like when you're out of
form and blitz and like my brother is
watching me and he's like jen it's a
blitz game
but you're just getting so wrapped up in
the position it's so interesting you
want to play a good move that's exactly
what maurice is saying it's such an
interesting game the reason why the
players are taking
six and a half minutes out of their 10
because that's unreal knock has used two
minutes for the last two moves
that's that's just unbelievable for but
guess what he is hikaru nakamura he is a
bullet player he will blitz out 40 moves
in a minute i mean the guy is that quick
so we'll see but will it be good moves
as he is now being pressured by kasparov
and by the way gary preserved his bishop
with the move bishop c2 a6 kicking back
the knight knight quickly jumped back to
d4 covering the fi square c5
a very very big strategic move
look at that look at that outpost on d5
uh
it's just begging for the white knight
to show up
that's right very tricky position but
now uh
getting a strong piece of his own knight
c4 forcing the queen back to c1 and gary
has played that exactly but how does
nakamura continue to make use of that
knight on on c4 because b3 could be
played next well indeed f5 is almost you
gotta
you gotta
f5 on the board otherwise knight f4
knight d5 is a strategic a hammer line
b3 chasing the knight followed by
bringing the queen back into the game
would be natural both sides both sides
basically at a minute and a half in this
very dynamic position
crazy chess at work right now in this
game
like back to b6 the f pawn still can't
be touched because of the the knight
hiding on e2 exactly and very quickly
while he pushes his pawn if we could
just jump to the other position this one
is on fire
i mean absolute chaos on this board look
at those black pawns steaming down the
board and just fearlessly throwing the
pawns forward it's fabiano caruana with
an awesome position just simply
dominating wesley so right now the
knight on c7 looks ridiculous and in the
meantime all of black's pieces are
charging up the board with a vicious
attacking possibilities for him meantime
kasparov on the other game has cemented
a night on the e4 square after a trade
and this has to be a bit better for
white right now absolutely i mean that
move c7 c5 was a big strategic decision
um i don't know if ikaru judged it
correctly but at the moment this knight
on b6 a little bit out of play and this
knight on e4 is a monster well he did
his best but he probably missed the
knight e4 queen c1 f5 that he wasn't
getting quite as much play as he
designed yeah oh it's very easy to slip
uh their gen in that position too late
for that now gary with 111 icaru with 52
seconds and counting down what to do he
has to play d5 it looks like otherwise
knight c3 keeping that uh pawn backward
on d6 and don't let a4 a5 show up on the
board and d5 might have been met by
knight c3 actually i'm not sure that
he's not losing a pawn in that position
he had to back up
he just played queen f8 instead and
where is he trying to get counter play
here guys i'm not sure
again one five that's what's gonna be as
though it takes d6 let me know g5 has
been played knight g5 instead with the
trying to trying to get yourself into
that e6 square and that move is really
the move that the engines like knight
takes d6 was a little bit tricky but
this move knight to g5 and positional
chest controlling the game nakamura down
to 24 seconds and borrowed
that night on b6 is the problem and only
15 14 seconds left for nakamura against
58 seconds by kasparov of kasparov way
ahead on the clock in 1997
but don't we have queen e8 check and
then after knight f8 96 no there's a
mate still hanging there's a mate
so we need to start with h4 no start
with queen e8 check knight f8 what
you're saying and then h3 or h4 make
your lift and then knight on f8 is
horrible and we're very excited
back and now he just needs to not hang
mate on the back row three
three why not each four just pre oh you
were i was the page of h6 and the knight
would be close to so h3 and knight f7
check big threat in the position and
he's changing
look at 94 guys
playing a master piece here no the only
problem is that there are some
perpetuals against white's king yeah
and here he goes with his king marching
towards the center of the board
it looks like there is no perpet queen
b2 king up and that's done
with h4 at some point i don't believe it
gary says show me you can't take with
the king there's knight g6 in the
position the queen takes h4 yes
and 11 seconds on the clock and
desperation by naca now trying to keep
things complicated and look at this
beautiful centralizing move queen e4
maurice queen f6 being played
one second left for hikaru that's
not exactly accurate but check and now
yeah because gary's got it all under
control there's a mate threat and no
there isn't not any more anymore tonight
the clock times three seconds eleven
seconds for gary a train of queens a
train of queens
is up it's over
kasparov against the favorite the beast
look at gary
relaxing as he walked away you say i can
teach these youngsters a thing or two my
goodness two in a row
and nakamura now now solidifying his
pitch in the basement but wait the other
game's not over absolutely
looks like a piece up a bishop for a
pawn
so bobby's going to maintain the lead he
was half a point ahead if he can do this
technically he's got only 12 seconds
left on the clock can he figure out the
right maneuver to win this game it looks
like that's a weird ending that is it's
not easy to assess right away bravely
pushing forward i'm sure it's got to be
oh it's over now yeah it's just got to
be now it's over now it's over because
he can just bring his king you can't
force the g4 move because we always have
f4 exactly we meet we
yeah i mean white wants to trade upon
wait a minute they just danced with
kings all around just a second ago it's
a triangulation uh
idea it didn't work and fabi is moving
his bishop back and forth but he's not
but he hasn't made progress he hasn't
made any progress in the last few moves
then he there he goes again he's not
getting any time extra so he has to
figure out how to win this position he
doesn't see any way to win and the
engines are now saying the position is
actually drawn that he has thrown away
the win and he has no way to win easily
anymore it's going to require a blunder
on the part oh but king f4 king of four
was a big threat king of four and g4 and
there he goes again it's a draw it's a
different job it's been a draw it's
definitely a draw
there's no way to win this position
anymore we can never play bishop and
he's calling threefold repetition he's
calling a people
i think he's right i think he's right
that this position has occurred three
times and we will get a confirmation on
that
let me see
uh what a fascinating endgame fortress
i've never seen one like this before i
asked i know with the bishop on h1 what
a wheel line yeah
usually the bishop's on c6 or something
like that and there's international
arbiter tony rich checking
with the monitors that this that
three-time repetition
is correct andrews are saying the
mistake was f5 pushing the pawn at all
he has gotten the 3-4 repetition right
here if we come right here to this
position yeah engines are saying that
this was the problem that black could
have repositioned himself in the
position by bringing his pieces around
and
i guess my game is auto updating so let
me pull that off
and go back to
this position here yeah and again
somebody's got control of my board so
i'm not going to fight but now it's auto
is auto updating to the position but
that moment when he played f5 was the
critical mistake in the game that cost
him the position because his pawn was so
far advanced that became a target in the
position and that's what it was
wesley fighting back not losing that
game getting a draw but gary kasparov
surging as well
from the win in the last round so now we
see that gary is drawn even with fabi
with wesley a half a point behind and
who would have thought nakamura would be
at one and a half points as the field
starts to distance themselves and he's
dropping back he's going to have to pull
some wins together if he's going to come
back in this competition and nakamura it
might be the man to do it but indeed uh
very unhappy we've got some great
spectators here um tweeting at our our
our hashtag ultimatelist st louis shout
out to aniz jiri who's actually with us
and he says that he's scored an hdmi
cable for team gary i think that has
something to do with him watching the
games but he's actually i noticed his
previous tweet was pretty hilarious it
says not the best result but good
company and good food are the most
important things in life i believe he
stole that totally stolen
he's kind of digging
trash talking oh man
step on the guy's neck when he's down
absolutely that's not right
we need you come on over baby yeah we
like we like the trash talk and there we
have some beautiful photos i like that
but guys uh
fantastic us champion fabiana cariwana
even with gary kasparov at this moment
is this what you expected jenna well no
i actually expected fabiano and nakamura
to be in the lead not at the end of the
day but we aren't at the end of the day
yet no we're gathering halfway there
right and how about you maurice what did
you what do you think about these
match-ups and the what's going on again
i agree i'm surprised at how poorly
nakamura is doing right now fabian
expected to be right at the top no
question about it and gary kasparov
starting quickly he had one hiccup with
that blunder against wesley but he's
showing he is a competitor how many
gorgeous games could this man have
played if he had not retired in 2005 he
is such a such an incredible player the
artistic
achievements the artistic advancements
the creations that he would have done
based on his work ethic is just amazing
we could only guess at that but now he
is
a sicilian now no we're going to see it
not no
this will also be a rich strategic
battle it's not a bishop b5 check
sicilian it is the imbalance line where
we've got bishop take c6 and the two
bishops were gary on the board
wow very balanced position on the other
in the other game as well as ikaru and
and wesley are in this position we see
here these players are blitzing we'll
catch up with them but this is
rather sliding his queen to age four
that's a real thematic idea in the
russell lumo actually white often gets
an attack um could you actually switch
that uh oh sorry can you update the
board there so i am i was okay i think
we're updated and uh after queen h4 the
nice thing is that we can sometimes
develop our bishop on c1 when one move
to bishop to h6 robbing gary of his two
bishop advantage and really putting the
king under pressure yeah very quickly
guys just take just to quickly look at
this other position how imbalanced it is
we see wesley and ikaru ikaru s8 bishop
g5 the trompowsky traded and this one is
going to be rich as well two great
fights in the imbalanced pawn structure
on both boards exactly but keep in mind
that fabi and gary are the uh the two
leaders in the competition and how
meaningful this game is to the
competition at this exact moment that's
right now he took an a5 now bobby
thinking because he has he has some
choices here he could just play bishop
h6 or or take an e5 immediately and he
did choose to take on e5 immediately
remember when you played bishop h6 i
could play f6 my bishop on g7 is
protected i could be
i could
snap off that pawn not so sure the
compensation is there right so knight
takes but now
the direct threat so how do you think
gary's going to deal with that queen d4
is how i deal with that jen i offer the
trade queen
i don't have queen e7 because you have
king e7 knight c6 and mike and then your
queen is protected gary opted for queen
d6 for the moment
i like that queen before d4 because if
you trade
i have a knight c2 threat at the end and
i've defended the bomb but the engine is
like rook to d4 against queen d4 so rook
to e4
looking for shutting down the train
c6 or queens queen c7 or queen d6 were
the best choices there and that was the
choice again so gary charles queen d6
which which was not as good according to
the engines not as perfectly good as
queen c7 but still a very good move uh
nevertheless
maybe not ideal so the knight has
dropped back we can also play 94 in all
these positions exactly i don't like the
move queen d6 yes queen d6 is not as
good as queen c7 because of
tempo that's just begging to be played
and you know as a blitz player you're
always looking to create threats as soon
as possible especially with knights
especially with knight this was not a
karpovian choice by gary kasparov he
should have put his queen on c7 out of
danger but now fabiano is a fabiano on
the move right yeah and he's no it's
gary on move right now after the night
drop back and gary's realizing that that
he allowed this idea of knight to e4 and
remember we said he was on the edge
every single game on the clock
look at this now almost a minute and a
half and ticking quickly down as he
realizes that white pieces are going to
naturally stream towards his king knight
on e4 bishop on 869 on g5 the attack is
clean for white that queen d6 move
proving to be a problem for him and he
needs to figure out exactly what to do
to defend against it the engines are
giving moves like bishop f6 as number
one h6 that he played was not even on
the list of best moves according to the
engine because now he can't castle on
that side just a quick bishop
playing on both sides of the board now
i mean h6 is basically saying i've got
to come up with g5 which is not a happy
circumstance gary not at all
quickly nice centralization
always remember
control of the center is so critical and
he's playing the first move of the
engines by the way is bobby bishop e3
instantly queen e4 instantly gary down
on the clock he's almost down two
minutes on the clock now as his fobby's
turn this is where you want to be when
you're playing a blitz game
lots of time on the clock right out of
the opening now we got castles in the
position does a knight be five snag a
pawn or do you or do we have some issues
all right
yeah
that after i i wouldn't even mind giving
up an exchange
because with my king so exposed after
these g5 h6 moves
i would be happy to bail out i'm more
afraid if i was black in this position
about just super strong moves like
h2h4
rook on a1 to d1 i'm more worried about
what's happening in my king i wouldn't
try to go after the rook on a8 or the
pawn on a7 and you know what i was going
after the pawn on season exactly
the thing about these
girls greedy girls you've got to play
80 moves quickly you don't want to look
for 100 moves unless they're just
completely evident you need to play
moves that are maybe an eight on the
scale if you can or a seven even a seven
as long as you're playing them quickly
you don't wanna blunder but a move like
rook ad one is automatic it's just in
the position he's now looking hard for
some deep plan his two minute advantage
he could have pressed on kasparov but
now his time ticking down and he has
less than a minute edge on the clock
that was not a good decision here i
think by fabi he should have just played
quickly
and he's just is he going to go but
locus bar up after having a two minute
edge not good policy here in blitz wow
and now he's played queen back to c2
he saw the move f5 coming but
it wasn't that serious a threat after
rook over it was just a move in the
position and f5 is on the board anyway
he didn't stop it it's there
and again rook d1 is the natural move
again because gary posted his queen on
the wrong square d6 it's a target rook
ad1 is an automatic as maurice was
saying but you know one thing pulls
another it's like a a a
needle and a thread the first the moves
h6 then came g5 now gary's weakening
this king further with the move f5 but
he had to stop knight e4 and
a lot of weaknesses appearing in
and black's position that can fabby take
advantage of it that's right we're
thinking
seven on the board we've been waiting
for some time for this move rook d1 this
is the future is the idea so he's things
off with knight d4
very strong
d4 because then then black's just left
with those weaknesses exactly exactly
jenna exactly the other game is pretty
balanced right now e5 we can meet with
bishop c5 right that was the automatic
and now the bishop can post up
dramatically on d6 but he can also use
the the d6 square to to enter with his
rook rookie bishop d6 bishop d6 was his
choice and a decent one at that queen f7
quickly played by gary you know but it's
strange dude with this spawn on g5 and
he hasn't white has not undermined this
pawn he hasn't played h4 so suddenly
black's king is actually pretty safe
black's happy right now bobby spent all
that time thinking about the position
and now they just saying black is only
slightly worse
in the position and gary despite all
that thought now gary's the one looking
for some initiative after c5 not backing
down not backing down one bit the
engine's like black it's interesting
that now black is the one who's ahead
gary turning the game around and look at
him standing stalwart like a bull and
fabi just having fritted away all his
time advantage is now going way behind
on the clock
he's he just got outplayed completely
yeah his night the big problem for him
is knight on c3 is no bueno i mean what
are we doing with that night exactly
what are we doing with them should we
re-relocate it
that would that would make perfect sense
and that's what and that's what bobby's
done he's played knight e2 that
principle of the worst piece the knight
not going to see to d5 or b5 bishop
bishop 86 on the board bishop a6 on the
board i was about to say bishop e6 but
he's headed to the dc3 square with that
bishop and it's posted into the d3
square right now that bishop's super
strong on d3 and gary knows he has the
edge here
this is the other game look at that
bishop queen a4 instantly played we have
to because we got to guard d4
yes and the pawn on a2 as well so what
does gary do now the pawn on c6 at the
moment is hanging for black i'd rip that
knight off on d4 instead he's played
charged ahead with f4 whoa
gary not caring about measly pawns
he's trying to attack and look at this
maurice f3 he's been playing let's
update that
knight c6 f3 and you know queen h5 v4
we know the principle of
the light scores the knight is going
back to the b4 square what is he's
trying to chase the bishop but the
bishop can go even more into black into
white's position the incursion of this
bishop now a dominating position for
kasparov absolutely and look at big big
threat alert e
4 e 3 and white's king
at mercy of the queen
bishop and one played but you're right
yes what's he going to do against this
idea actually the engines thought that
the best thing was to trade queens as
quickly as possible because e3 now on
the board simply crushing we have
why what happens after queen b3 and it
has been played there's a rook e6 isn't
it
there's a takes on f2 and a bishop d4
monster move he can hide can he hide on
g three that's all on the board guys so
we're going
on no
no there's a rook e6 also so i don't i'm
not no no gary has three katy queens and
played f
two when did he get in f2 he's traded to
queens and he's played f2 oh
oh
oh oh
u.s champion
under great
duress here
gary's best game so far in the blitz
well gary's going to find out best games
gary's playing some serious chess rook
now over to h1
fabi down to only 21 seconds on the
clock h1 what a lame move what what else
could he do what is rookie three check
no it's king f2
oh my gosh no but rookie three check is
crushing king have to drop the bishop
back and there's all kinds of vicious
discoveries the other rook is planning
to come into the game at some point
rookie two check i
[Music]
he can of course win the exchange by
just pushing his pawn but he wants more
107 left on the clock and he's in this
position this is one of the problems in
blitz you want 100 move he's in a
position where he feels like there's a
win he smells it he knows there's
something here he's spending his time
carry on with only 22 seconds
while gary has 53 seconds he's been
thinking for how many maybe like 40
seconds right now and his time is
sticking down quickly he's gonna have to
make a practical decision at some point
exactly he knows he's got to win he
doesn't want to just play a move like
bishop takes b2 picking a bomb picking
up an exchange he doesn't want to play
and he's finally playing the movie
wanted to play the whole time will he
find bishop b5 no he played rook to e8
instead after king takes and now rook a
to e8 and the engines are saying that's
not as accurate
perfect defense by carano with knight to
c6 on the board
expecting to play some kind of
king defense after the rook moves where
to put the rook he's playing rook f3
king double check e1 every double check
we don't get to see that a lot allowing
him
jack so it's not the end oh my gosh 97.
sack of the exchange followed by two
bishops versus a rook and two beautiful
play by gary i'm not sure
two bishops versus a rook and two pawns
i believe maurice yes it is two pawns
it's it's bad according to the engine oh
yeah for white but it's not as obviously
bad as you would want
but that those bishops are going to be
hard to play against
it's true it's true
and b4
does that allow
you know bishop
yes bishop takes b2 on the board now
those bishops are slicing into the
position gary just has to make moves now
18 seconds for him 12 seconds for fabian
as they take down and king g7 and bishop
d3 and he's one of them
but that goes past that past c pawn
could be dangerous and look at that
collect pawns
the game has changed dramatically it's
no longer an easy win that's right not
at all and now gary has to figure out
what to do as fabi sees that he he can
certainly create problems for black
and gary looking a little shaky here is
he's moving his rook but bobby is king
coming into the position as well
absolutely
providing great counter play that extra
piece
of ship on g2 it's not a marching check
and the king could go forward but that's
going to create a perpetual check chance
so he's backed up in the position
how is gary going to win this he just
played the move bishop to e2 allowing
this captain to check
and now a sacrifice by kasparov to
create what looks like a drawn end game
that's beautifully done wow
what a save a draw again gary you've got
that face
look at that face we talked about
internet man oh my god and that is
internet man number two of it
there
are we sure the result was a great draw
it was a great draw yeah wow gary felt
like he he let one get get away here he
played beautifully up to that moment
with e3 f3 he went after carrion's king
that was a fantastic game guys i feel
like we're just being treated to
masterclass
nakamura because they're not
actually this is just exhausted
i'm ex oh uh fortress yeah this is a
fortress nakamura is in right now it
looks as though he cannot be breached
everything about his position is ideal
the king cannot get in the white the
black king especially cannot get into
this position so he can virtually offer
a draw and it will be accepted matter of
fact his last move
his last move is attacking the pawn and
forcing this to go back forcing the king
to go backwards and now he's actually
pushed wesley's king backwards he's
going to pick off the b-pawn in this
position take a look at this nakamura
will it be yours
he just turned it all around not just
completely turning
what is this maurice
white was playing for a fortress
position and now white has the edge
and it looks like it looks like it's not
quite there because black and black and
just do the opposition keep the king
keep the king out so
wesley has found that as well it looks
like it should be a draw as long as his
king can stay up this is the moment
and now f3 looking for the win f3 11
seconds left guys they've got to blitz
out moves and he's forced the king back
and now he's just ditching his pawn on
b3 as wesley to get play on the other
side and there goes the pawn how is he
going to save this
oh my goodness how's he going to save
this it looks like naka has figured out
a way to win the pawn and now here comes
the king
wesley now just trying to survive he
still looks like there's drawing
boundaries here for sure they have to
just play quickly
vidiqaru nakamura
from a worse position has the upper hand
no question about that can he convert
his one pawn advantage doesn't look like
it's really possible
bishop f5 trying to trade off this
bishop that i think wesley should get
his king maybe to f5 no oh
now it looks winning
it looks winning it's not issues
on e4 there it is oh he's in trouble now
and he's got to think yeah you have to
think is bishop g8 is coming bishop g8
is a key move and now the king's going
to march into f5 and wesley
[Music]
right here when wesley played the move
b5 b4 that was when things went south if
he had just left this pawn on b4
hikaru could have done nothing in the
position boy it's way back
but it's right here it's right here that
move b3 that was the key moment if he
hadn't played b3 it would have been a
draw and the thing is he cannot make any
progress anyway even with b3 the king on
b2 is so strong he actually went for it
let us point out by the way that game
took resignation
96 moves they played 96 moves of chess
in that one right they're playing
marathon games trying to
get a win what do you have to do to get
a win but naka did what he had to do
because he was in the cellar and now
surging with another point and we see
here fabiano caron at three and a half
as is gary kikaru and wesley trailing at
two and a half there's still anybody's
show here as they are fighting chess
today and we let's take a look at gary
has five and the charity he's playing
for he might be giving quite a lot of
money the way he's playing um
what is gary playing for
in the ultimate bliss gary kasparov has
elected to donate his women winnings to
the u.s chess olympiad team and we are
going to have a super strong olympiad
team this year so his support is very
much appreciated up to 20k if you end up
winning this
well i guess the olympic members
will be well compensated one way or the
other right
yeah that's very very generous
and we are going to take a quick break
and then we're going to be back with the
third and final quad here at the
ultimate a blitz challenge in st louis
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to the ultimate
bliss challenge here at the st louis
chess club we are in round three
of three quads today and let's take a
look at the standings as we go into the
final quad of day one kerry kasparov he
is playing stunning chess he's got three
and a half points and he's tied with
fabiano caruana wesley so in gm
wednesday so in nakamura um both with
two and a half so it's real bunched up
of course gary kasparov playing the most
beautiful chats just absolutely
strategic but sometimes wondering a
little bit but hey everybody's
blundering back astonishingly chess
world this is this is historic it's it's
fantastic his achievement thus far has
been
so impressive
he's been crazy let's take a look at
this opening that he's playing against
wesley cell i've got the wrong p i've
got the wrong pgn file i apologize well
i got position right
you know this position on this board
first game we've seen him play unusually
in this position after e6 instead of
playing d4 he played b3 and after b6
bishop to d3 so definitely going out of
opening theory with this move let's get
up to the game right now as we see this
position on the board and the last move
has been queen c7 by
wesley kg move
eyeballing this pawn on e4 asking gary
what his intentions are rookie one
preparing to re-fortify the move the
pawn on e5 and i think gary is really
preparing the move c4
as he has as he hasn't committed his
pawns yet but um
i like what gary's doing frankly in this
opening position i've been very oh he
has played the bishop b2 i was about to
say i would have been curious about the
move knight c3 in that specific position
that didn't happen bishop b2 was his
choice and you're going to like the
other game as well as wesley has played
them with b5 on that board in the other
position we see naka steam his h-pawn
down the board in this position as you
see here despawn went down the board of
trade and rooks have traded off and now
bishop to g5 so this position
usually can start off sharp it was
indeed a kind of dutch formation well
turned into a dutch but this one maybe
have simplified a little bit and less
exciting strategically at least for the
moment both sides right now both games
not wild opening lines
in the positions just solid play but
interesting play to say the least but
this move b5
quite a tricky little move this is not
this is the kasparov game we're seeing
right here although to the right we have
wesley sorry we have hikaru and fabi and
now we have this position on the board
really like what gary is what just
happened yeah he just just won the c4
square that night on c4 i uh
particularly effective outposts right
because in a sicilian
wesley i really like it because we can
play nike six as well and by the way
did you see that very determined way
that gary made the move d4 i mean he
played it like
boy let me emphasize the oomph behind
that one isn't it amazing how gary is
out playing these youngsters i mean just
absolutely incredible he's getting them
every single game now knight to f4 and
kasparov just
leaned back like what is that about oh
bad he does not respect that move not
one bit i don't either i just don't like
this move one bit queen d2 give me that
tempo thank you very much get your night
out
trying perhaps to uh to get one piece in
the defensive because he has no pieces
over there in the king side with uh the
move knight g6 but that would be the
most important thing about the position
is a better position in the middle of
the board for gary and he's played queen
d2 that's right that's an automatic and
by the way if wesley if wesley's not
careful this rook is going to come over
to the c1 file eyeballing the black
queen and would be not
rick takes e4 and be careful about the
rover as well
just a lot of ghosts hanging over
black's position here i don't like this
one bit for wesley if he survives you
got to tip your hat but i don't like it
yeah he's just got no defender so here
and gary's just simply taking on c5
absolutely because that opens up the
bishop on b2 and makes the move 96 super
attractive
bishop a three in the position
i like that one
two moves here the engines actually also
like the move rook to g4 and just as i'm
saying it kasparov plays it rook to g4
putting pressure on that side as well
the main point for black is that knight
on b8 that knight on b8 is terrible the
rook on e8 those pieces are out of the
game white right now can always play
rook c1 and look at this the king has
moved there was some kind of issues on
the a6 square so he moved this king so
gary made an improving move and now the
knight leaping to g5 and kasparov is on
the attack
again and he just feels it look at the
body posture he's leaning over the board
he is just on the attack and he smells
it wesley's so in trouble yeah this is
gary kasparov in his element
this is fantastic
whoa
queen d3 this is gonna be a huge move um
gary didn't play it though he played it
looks like he's moved his knight back to
e4
yeah queen to d3 actually allowed bishop
takes nine on g5 yeah so he didn't play
that movie brought his knight back
although knight d6 the engines were
given a strong as well knight d6 was the
strongest move now wesley just
scrambling with this line 94 queen a7
and now strategically a knight can go
into d6 yet again guys what about knight
f6 knight f6 tricky move tricky move to
be sure but it's not apparently not a
prime move as far as the engines are
concerned they're seeing a knight going
into d6 that's strategically superior in
this position and trouble a foot knight
put a knife from c to d6 and maybe on
the next move you could drop a knight on
f6 the position is just horrible right
now for black true although it looked a
tiny even tiny bit better a couple moves
ago like
some of these ideas like knight to d6
and keeping our knight on g5
guys just a quick question knight d6 you
know in blitz that's the type of move
that's just begging to be played as
you're threatening rook g7
if you take
queen h6 rook g8
takes
and if you go back
i've got these ideas of rook g7 this is
the type of tactics that gary kasparov
is calculating right now but guess what
he's using a lot of time burning a lot
of clock and it doesn't work even though
knight f6 was strong knight f6 looked
like and he's reached for his c4 night
but he didn't
actually no because the rook gets h7
made in that other line precisely he
needs to play knight he needs to play
quickly now he's got 141 he's still
calculating lines what did he play okay
i got him he moved his rook into the
game he moved his rope to d1 and now
he's played it clearly he was thinking
about that move yes he was definitely
thinking about it and now he's this
piece is sitting on the f6 square
and
the engines like it they say that it's
an advantage the same advantage he had
before pressing now knight takes e5
being the number one move for the engine
knight takes on e5 as being the only
real move to keep the game going will
wesley find that move knight takes is
they're claiming even forced
for like for him yeah this is this g7
idea is just very nice
flowing up the king side seven queen g5
king h8 queen h6 and um you're incapable
of defending h7 so
you always advise your your students
whenever you're on the attack make sure
you you invite everybody to the party
gary first brought his rook to d1 very
instructional and wesley has found his
only defense only to stay in the game 95
we're expecting bishop takes eve the
first time takes on e5
was the best sequence and he found all
amazing sequence just happened by the
way and now knight takes was that all
accurate
night it's all been played and f6 is on
the board now the question is is this
knight on e7 far what whoa this queen f4
in the position guys
queen f4
oh my goodness actually even stronger is
what gary just played knight to d6
dominating the board look at the
beautiful
cavalry charge
crushing position
an a4 just an anemic move being thrown
out there there's got to be some
combination swirling right now
absolutely
remember when gary was with us he said
that having the the knights on d6 and e6
were worth two rocks gary's down to 110
though and b4 in that position b4
creating a pass pawn at any point will
be strong just create a passport
yourself what is he supposed to do about
b4 b5 start marching down the board he
needs to first he's made love by driving
the knight back from g4 to h6 he made it
with a gain of tempo that has he he
found it before
on the board and we can also play bishop
d4 and stick our bishop on c5 i just
love that
and and wesley had to stop uh jennifer
what you were just about to suggest
bishop to d4 bishop c5 would have been
positional overkill that didn't happen
because leslie played queen b6 so now
bishop d4 queen takes d6 so trying to
get a sliver of players but very quickly
this move rook c4 i don't know if that
was accurate i would have preferred the
move b4 b5 yeah but the agent is saying
this is crushing this this really yeah
this is looking bad for west ham because
rook h4 and a sacrifice on h6 is coming
fast he needs to move his knight off of
off of that square quickly because he's
about to get mated and he did not he
moved his queen back to d8 queen back to
d8 and now knight c8 how did he find
that move so quick that is the best move
on the board according to the engines
gary just playing incredible chess on
every move now knight c knight f5 has
been played push the pawn b5 come on
gary
get now queen to c2 he's just owning the
board now with his knife
what is that
i love that queen defending the the d6
knight he's just controlling the board
he's played queen d3
i'm not sure i like these
queen d3 i like ready to play rook h4
now again
gary's been playing number one or two
moves by the engine every single move he
is totally in control of this game right
now but the problem is he only has 37
seconds left on his clock finally being
really behaved i've been bishop c3
bishop b4
and he snaggled upon with queen a3
has he allowed no rook b5 doesn't work
f8 is hanging
rook b595 queen c4 queen we've got some
more moves in the board queen d5 trying
to get some counter play desperately
rook c1 gary and queen c5 that oh queen
bee yes queen c5 posting up that he's
got his screen on b4 he opted out and
played queen b4
in that position he played queen before
not queen c5 i've got queen c5 now he's
playing queen to b4 is queen is sitting
on b4 right now
in the game queen to b4 and it doesn't
matter he owns the board everything he
did so far is right he is completely
controlling the chess board the b pawn
about to run down the knight on d6 is
dominant he gets it he just has 33
seconds to prosecute this advantage he
has been playing dominating chess to
look like he could mate on the other
side but he decided to own the other
side of the board and the way he's done
it he just played very practically and
now his b-pawn is just a monster
and it's over it's just a crushing
position taking on a2 doesn't change
anything that's the thing that doesn't
even get a much counter play it's just
played bishop t3 you notice how all the
pieces
are pretty much defended except for that
work on c1
and just just pushing forward with b6
um getting the other rookies
didn't that happen twice to wesley
against wesley yeah gary playing a
monster game a beautiful beautiful
street
a flawless strategic victory in the
offing and look at this
after the move rook v8 b7 dropping the
knight on d6 what a tragic mistake for
gary kasparov
wow and the other game well it harkens
back to that early blunder that he made
against nakamura gary playing the best
but a few too many blunders
in this this splits that's the problem
with blitz while these two are in an
equal ending but white is pressing in
this position no icaru looks pretty good
your car looks pretty good here well i
i'm judging i'm judging from the engines
analysis that that is holdable at least
although white is definitely the one
who's pressing up a pawn but the
opposite colored bishops will he be able
to save the game and it looks like he
has ripped off the c pawn
off the board and he's looking to take
the a pawn as well after knight to e3 a4
already on the board and now here comes
the black king
bishop chasing the king backwards king
move didn't work out but here comes the
night now it doesn't look as though he
has enough with the game
right now he's won a piece he's up
against at the moment uh the d4 pawn is
the problem that's
and now upper piece is nakamura can he
win this position and he's going after
the c pawn now can he trade knights
that's going to be his fantasy look at
the knight in bishop pure my goodness i
hope he knows how to check me with a
with a bishop and a knight
goes off the board he does
only four seconds on the clock no way
really he's only four seconds on the
clock i think there's a check mating
pattern already coming up uh in the
position knight c4 is a practical move
as played well the a6 pawn is going to
drop now and it looks like he's going to
drop any second
and there he goes
king b6 and get over there and take that
he's got to move he's got to find a move
his line is on a1 now
what
back out into the game the knight is
trapped actually on that side it looks
like he's decided to go find the knight
by somehow bring his knight his king
back and take the knight on a1 how does
he get out
king back he's still going and now king
b2 looks like oh no he has to be careful
he has to be slightly careful about this
ending because the opposite color the
wrong color bishop
dropping the bishop back nope he's not
going to work hiding his pieces away
from nakamura and now it's oh now it's
over the night is trapped beautifully
done by nakamura nakamura saying hey
this tournament ain't over yet i mean we
we're almost like exactly tied we are
exactly tied both leaders lost oh great
everybody
the whole time for first tournament
but first let's play again wait a minute
is that right let's let's double check
let's take a look at our standings in
the st louis ultimate blitz challenge
uh stunning uh
and i think everybody's tied
i think they all have three and a half
points
three and a half points for everybody
a huge wow blunder by gary kasparov to
uh
forced this condition had he won that
winning position he would have had a
point lead that's not the case everybody
tied for first
and nobody nobody suffers better than
gary kasparov we love his faces let's
take a look at what happened to him in
the game where he blundered earlier
oh brutal that was against nakamura i
believe and there was another great
faith
that was wrestling
that was mostly
and he needed another one yeah where and
i also think it was against westlake yes
okay so two
horrific
it was against wesley you played knight
c3 in the groom fellaini and rooks he
won right right
he wanted
actually blundering at night in both
games blundering knight both times the
knight on c3 and then the knight on d6
and just twice two such controlled
performances against leslie so
hey like nakamura you gotta give some
credit to so um just stick it staying in
the game staying that's
that's costing him as he's spending a
little bit too much time even in
dominating positions blitz is not about
playing perfect just like i said what
you want is to play
eighty percent moves if you can you look
start looking for ninety percent moves
100 moves those
moves cost time seconds take away and
now can gary rebound from two
devastating losses
how much can you take how much can your
nervous system take and to bounce back
as he has a couple more games to play
today gary's kind of been known to be
able to come back from losses but the
point there is gary should be feeling
very good because he's no he he knows
that he's been playing the best chess in
the event so far well i don't know if he
knows that we know that he doesn't know
what time he knows
he knows it hey he i mean he's just
playing outstanding
what he does know is that
these young boys don't have anything for
him that's what he knows he knows that
he's able to hang and he just has to be
consistent and we've got very confident
about we've got him starting yet again
f3 remember against in the u.s
championships uh hikaru played against
chandra this formation
and um
won a very impressive game except this
is gary
yeah the business
and the very early bishop g5
um
not
my favorite way of playing it for white
yukari nakamura very familiar with these
systems he plays them on both sides as
well i remember when the last time these
two faced off they spent an inordinate
amount of time in the first 20 moves and
it kind of looks like it's going in that
direction again with a 20-minute tank on
seven very unusual for blitz
now gary has not played the move h7 h6
big controversy theoretically about
whether or not you want to put the pawn
on h6 he's chosen
uh not to do it in this particular case
in this particular line of the medoni
and a big decision i think gary's still
kind of shaking his head i think he
still hasn't recovered from the shock of
hanging a piece the round before and in
the other game they have a position that
is somewhat tepid uh if we take a look
quick look at that position somewhat
tempted position with trades it looks
like if you're not looking at gary
casparo's game the other game is
probably boring i mean it's weird how
the openings are going the place has
solid openings on the other boards and
caspar you look at this you say this is
not theory this is my main line you look
at this and you go whoa full-blooded
battle in some benoni sharp structure
every single game it looks like gary is
playing opening theory white or black
totally principal player making all the
games rich and interesting maurice you
and i both know uh what a dynamic player
gary
was in his heyday the the intensity that
he brought to the chessboard
is it missed
it's
especially after seeing him back today
yeah what he's just what he's shown in
this first day of competition has been
stellar i i i mean i'm in awe we need
more gary kasparov blitz matches that's
what everybody on the internet is saying
everybody on the internet agrees that's
kind of unusual whoa
i mean you got it wow he's just
tremendous and look at him he's playing
again the most most principled
on this guy's battle for how many world
championships i understand
he he knows so much about positions
understanding he's playing off the stuff
that he's he's cooked up for years for
decades and yes he might be out of form
for classical chess spending all his
time now with his charity and and
political leanings and all of that but
this guy's still obviously a player and
it's just impressive to watch every game
beastly and
bishop e3 voluntarily coming back with
his bishop is hikaru nakamura he's
looking and he's seeing that this pawn
coming to b5 is going to be
giving black
excellent counter play on the queen side
the big question is should
gary preface the move b5 with the move
knight c5 or go for b5 instantly the
reason why you might not want to play b5
right away is there is this annoying a b
a b rook a7 you can't play rook b7
because then i can snip the pawn the
queen on b5 the queen would be forced to
go backwards um
not the initiative uh that gary would
like well show us if you if you do play
knight d5
in instead
of c4 will be left by that um will be
matched by knight takes e4 i assume yes
but um instead we
update on the board i just flip back and
forth we've gotten none of the above
discussion h55
oh my god quick uh rooksy one rook on
ftc one by nakamura trying to gang up on
that c4 pawn no question about it this
knight on g3 is in the wrong square it
would love to be
on the d2 square so it would be
pressuring the spawn on c4 so the move
h5 strikes me as mistimed and he's
yeah
pushed
not putting it on f1 where it has no
real future but putting it on h1 where
it can later go to f2 and guard some
important squares maybe h3 or g4
um but h3 by gary
that if we take that that when he moves
his um knight on d7 to c5 now we're
running bishop takes age three and
knight
on the other side caspar playing on two
sides of the board and the rook is now
on a7 and now he's shifting his queen
back to the d8 square what's going on as
the knight is now eyeballing after
knight f2 eyeballing the h3 pawn
absolutely but these are the sharp lines
that benoni players revel in after the
move knight c5 bishop takes c5 d takes
e5 white has this huge center but black
also with his bishop on g7 you know
waiting in ambush an opportunity to land
on the d4 square and gary double-edged
position
huge time pressure but he played the
nike e5 instead which i was also yeah
wondering that's a big decision there 95
or knight c5 definitely want to be
guarding that h3 pawn perhaps with the
idea that if f4
you could jump to g4 the idea of playing
h3 is that
now any f4 move weakens the square g4 so
that pawn on h3 still alive
has been played bishop d4
as we say
in the position now
and
the interesting after night after d7
that black is okay believe it i believe
it pretty good for black if you can just
bring his knight back reinforce the
knight on that square on that e5 square
and we'll be running knight d3 in those
types of positions too we'll have some
interesting like nike three ideas with
the bishop takes d4 hitting c1
absolutely you know intense strategic
game guys but i feel again the clock
being an issue he found the move but he
spent so much time he's down two and a
half minutes on the clock and he will
have to make complex decisions shortly
and this is the problem yeah thanks
congratulations you got the good
position but a few moves from now you're
gonna be under a minute and blunders as
we've seen pop up in his game so far
will begin to abound it's no accident
that he's blundering these pieces in
time pressure he's outplaying the
players but is the five minutes enough
for him to contain their tenacity their
threats their defense
it's it's proving to be difficult for
him so far and nakamura with a
two-minute edge on you on the clock
big big big time
mismanagement errors by gary in this
first day of competition i think there
is still a lot of rust in his game but
you see
what kind of player he was at his peak
and you know what
phenomenal
ideas and dynamic
uh yeah
attacking
moves he would make great opening
preparations as well also throw that one
in the mix one of the problems is his
positions are just so fascinating that
it's like brutal to have to make a quick
move like a super quick move and by the
way the reason i
i was wondering why the heck
is hikaru waiting on thinking about the
position i see that there's an idea of
queen f6
setting up for a discover
attack against the bishop on e3 and now
a very nice
reinforcing move by hikaru queen e3
preventing any ideas of harassing the
f-bomb question is does that walk into
the counter punch f5 or not because this
rook on e8 is in prime position knight
c5 incredible he did it again the
engine's first move a straight sacrifice
of a pawn bishop takes pawn takes and
queen takes now the move positionable
bishop to f8 is the suggested move but
how is he finding these moves he knows
plays b4 chasing the knight away again
the dark square bishop can reposition
itself and it's black with the
initiative here forcing the knight
backwards will he play the move bishop
back to
f8
he knows his dark square bishop is very
strong he's trying to figure out how to
use it but his time is ticking down 46
seconds flying down now to zero he's got
to find a way to make quick moves and
he's played bishop to d7 it's it's a
terrible situation for him now he's
playing so he's playing well but not
quickly enough he's trying to play
knight c6 in this position i think you
know
and if we did it with our bishop on c8
you have queen takes c6 that knight on
f2 is such a very nice defender isn't it
important
and now white has taken over the game
with the queen to c7 black's initiative
is sucked out of the position he did not
find the maneuver bishop back to f8 now
he is
not getting anything he's just not
getting anything for his pawn sacrifice
f4 is coming the pawn on c4 is gonna
hang this is a bad position for black
suddenly white has the game completely
under control and a queen trade is just
fantastic now happy for nakamura as he
sees the queens come off the board and
gary with only 15 seconds left guys this
is going to be a bad result for kasparov
fans i agree i agree maurice and what a
comeback for hikaru nakamura was it only
a moment ago that he was in the cellar
and how he if he wins this game and he's
in prime prime position to win this game
he'll be in first hope
whoever wins the other game and wesley
so is dominating that other game right
now against fabiano
was he so up in exchange
looking to win this game as he's going
after those weak pawns and caruana has
to defend for his life as wesley with
plenty of time on his clock look at the
time disparity guys unreal up in
exchange weak pawns everywhere he's
gonna start picking off the munchies and
caruana just in trouble these two
players karan and kasparov were leading
the tournament a couple of rounds ago
now suddenly they're going to be the
seller dwellers as nakamura and wesley
so have surged back looking to get two
wins ground's not over yet but still
terrible situation for
the elite the former leaders a couple of
rounds ago and we can switch back we see
hikaru still hasn't moved what hikaru
still hasn't moved we've talked all this
time and tikaru
still has not moved he's now under a
minute after trading queens how did this
happen
look uh gary 15 seconds
15 seconds
all that time he had like a two minute
advantage and now
he's finally played he played f4 he's
worried about this and quickly instantly
c3
was gary caspar and isn't there a knight
f1 check gary didn't do it it was bishop
b5 and takes on b2
has hikaru allowed his opponent back
into the game with these tactical shots
yes he has absolutely has gary needs to
find moose though king to h1 and his
clock is ticking down
and gary looks like he's inside
and we've got after g6 we have knight d2
played by harry that wasn't that's the
best move
and d7 rick v8 rook b2 bishop b2 oh my
goodness
look at this the time going down gary
has one in exchange but that pawn on d7
is huge yeah so we're but can you can
you
mean
with king e7
and oh by the way my gosh there's
another b-pawn for gary in the position
yes mike is winning but can he do it can
you spell it
trying to get a counter play with knight
and look at gary hesitated
[Music]
oh my goodness it is tense
and the king is now on d6 oh my goodness
and knocked his time about eight seconds
now
oh my goodness the knight just dropped
back to f6 now he can play knight to c6
he hasn't done so and he's gotten his
exchange back
but gary's got to move
threatening a knight on d3 not taking it
back right away
and now he's [ __ ] up to seven seconds
again he doesn't take on d3 because of
the fork he could not take he blundered
again
and now it's just a time situation rook
c6 driving the king back and now moving
the king over and kasparov is lost
kasparov is now down he's trying to make
his b-pawn work but he's gonna lose that
too
oh
very disappointed gary kasparov
can't believe what has happened to him
in this
cycle of
and the other game over as well did
wesley end up winning that game
or you thought that
not many people predicted with these uh
with the superstar blitz player hikaru
nakamura the u.s champion fabulano
carrana and the legend gary caspar of of
course wesley so top 10 player but
not picked by many people in fact we had
some polls on on twitter and really and
wesley was getting somewhere between two
and ten percent of the vote very little
compared to the other player so wesley
fans who bet big on him having a party
now um let's take a look at the scores
now as we said wesley stolen nakamura
tied for the league with four and a half
points each and of course within
striking distance these scores are so
tight caruana and gary kasparov so we
could all change again in the final
round
of today's action and by the way if we
take a look at wesley so in this
position blitz is just what it is here
fabiano excuse me has
come back in the game and actually is
drawing this position could play this
move rook check according to the engines
this is a great move very difficult for
you to get out of the mating net if you
believe that he just plays rook check
and chases your king away and these
pawns become very dangerous and if you
hang around then wait a minute you might
be trying for some trouble here as this
king moves forward ready to bring the
knight back play h7 and macho in the
back row the engines give this position
as dead equal but in time pressure he
played the move knight to f6 and then
they just go whoa wait a minute that was
not a good idea after check the king
went to h5 he actually repeated the
moves for just a second and then he
played this move rook to c5
and now he's just completely winning
this pawn is dropping there's no way to
hold the position together and wesley so
moved on and won that game and is now
tied for first place i would say if when
i looked at caspar of the way he started
it was so quick but when he blundered
when you play blitz blunders start to
take a toll on you faster than it does
in
in over the board over the board you
blended you can go home and clear your
mind in blitz when you blunder
you need to clear your mind on the spot
and then when you blunder again you
start feeling a trend in the same day in
the space space of just the same couple
of hours and now he's blundered a third
time as kasparov so he's he's in trouble
he's in trouble he's like a fighter
who's getting hit each time realizing
he's getting sucker punched and knowing
he's been playing so well
every single game
it wasn't clear to me how the game
finished so let's just take a look at
that game between uh kasparov
and uh hikaru it was a time scramble and
what a time scramble it was
uh gerry got to this position and
suddenly realized that after his move
rook d5 a big blunder there was knight
f7 and there's a big fork on e5 square
and the game continued like this and now
after check the king just got out of the
way from h1 no back rank mates and this
is how hekaru roped in the point
uh to get a share of first place and by
the way that moment you talked about was
the key moment when he played that rook
move all he had to do was just take them
take the knight in that position and he
would have had a simple equal at least a
fighting chance here well they've got it
would have been
would have gone off the board yeah he
would have gotten his draw but this was
the huge he played this move and fell
for this knight f7 trick he couldn't
take will he be able to hold up against
fabiano caruana who has also gone down
we're seeing two players desperate for a
win today just before winning this round
how they're going to come back after
being punched that's right terribly in
two games and we've got another e4 e5
and grandmaster gupta mentioned it on
twitter um kasparov keeps blundering
with his knight
fundraising knight forces
that's right all the three games
it's all about the knight in blitz our
two leaders wesley and akaro are posting
up but let's see how the u.s champion
knight c3 no scotch no scots this time
so keeping keeping us guessing and um
just playing knight c3 and bishop c4 but
a very strange joco piano that's not
quite yet a joke of piano by delaying
the move with knight f3 we got this f4
break
could we see a kind of a king's gambit
like play i bet you who we are
this is a sharp position to be sure but
we should be paying attention i think to
the display leaders
for the two leaders right now today's
round the leader from today's round will
be decided on the other board and they
are in a sharp game and we need to take
a good look at this one as wesley so has
steamed his pawns down the board and
we've seen this before yes i think this
is one of your kind of positions well in
fact it's a well-known theoretical
position unfortunately it's a tame one
uh karo nakamura has essayed this on
numerous occasions when he wants to draw
as black oh come on he's not going for a
troll on a bus game
well it is on the position first
see what you get after that but uh
wesley slow
always very well prepared he knows these
positions quite well himself
unfortunately i know that this is a
fight for first but it's a tame one and
one of these players one of these
players will be tied either clear first
or type of first after this game no
question about it one of these two will
either be in clear first or tie with a
win
they go to first actually they draw so
wait a minute switch that yeah either
they're tied themselves or one of them
surges to the lead so
very important position now
important gaming car was stopping to
think
and nasser wants to take a quick look at
the cast broad game because what's
happening white can't castle is he going
to be able to castle queen side
absolutely so that's what makes this so
dynamic now he's going to try to play
queen d tour queen e2 and castle long
and by the way
a big uh
i
don't want to say a mistake but
strategically speaking to allow this pin
and already having given the address of
your king on g8 this pin is very
annoying you don't want to allow those
double pawns but neither do you want to
play g5 and no question jennifer queen
d2
castle's long is definitely on white's
agenda because castling short
is impossible in the other game there's
a huge sacrifice that he can play
nakamura in this position that would
make the game just completely explode as
knight d4 has been played on that board
in this position and he played it he
played knight takes c5 and took on c3 so
knight takes pawn on c5 he's taken on c
pawn takes bishop takes c3 now bishop
takes a6 was played and the rook on a1
is indeed hanging and being given as
best
in this position
what not this game just suddenly
exploded and it's still supposed to be
just okay the rook on e1 of course is
hanging as well so he's got to take one
of them at some point
bishop a1 rook a1 queen a7 yes maurice
and it has taken and now that is exactly
right that has happened bishop back in
now queen c5 we have a very unbalanced
position appearing on the board a bishop
and a knight for a rook and two pawns
and 95
players to try to attack those minor
pieces are better in the middle game we
don't want to trade queens we don't want
an end game we need to get some kind of
attack in and queen c2 nibbling on
nakamura's king's side yeah and i
remember a game that nakamura lost to
eliana often in this exact
situation where it was a rook and two
pawns against two minor pieces the minor
pieces took hikaru down with this move
queen c2 there's a double threat against
this pawn on c6 meaning that white is
about to win one of his pawns back and
hikaru decided to give up his
h7 pawn which means his king
is going to be
perpetually right under uh
pressure doesn't have too many homes
does it i mean he takes h7 check king h8
the threat the threat is perhaps g6
he did not play the move just yet so
don't
mistake it he hasn't captured as yet
this is an automatic
and we're look i'm looking at this game
where the bishop is looking to cover
the position and
rook to b1 the engines gave rook to d1
as the best move there but
not fearing g6 because we can play
bishop he's sacrificing sacrifice and
then we're also coming in with rick p7
the other game is going very slowly by
the way the other game is going super
slowly but kasparov thinking a bit too
long yet again both sides playing slowly
but this one is sharp i really like it
yeah i really like the way
uh wesley has conducted himself thus far
i mean it's still a double-edged
position all results are possible but i
like the idea of a4 and rook b5 and wait
a minute there's another threat of queen
to d3 threatening to swing the queen to
the to the h file
he can get over there sneaky sneaky but
he's played rook to d1
but that's something that's hiding in
the position
no question about it maurice i thought
that it was high time to get the bishop
back to d3 and around h5 i think the
inclusion of rook b1 rook a7 is
extremely favorable for hikaru yeah
because now when we play g6 in certain
variations the rook also defends across
the seventh round
this is great for white according to
them bishop e4 get the bishop back out
of there quickly and
then look to somehow rearrange your
forces so you can get your queen over to
that side
sharp sharp position still but ken
wesley break through in some kind of way
and that's why he played rook d1
presumably to play bishop before exactly
mario
bishop you foresee foreign to follow
your idea maurice i like it very much
queen e2 hello
may i introduce queen h5 and mate
there it is he's now set up to rearrange
the battery between his queen and bishop
he wants to change places bishop and
queen and bishop e4 is a nice let's go
back start the position because c4
wasn't played so this black habit does
black have any better ideas here trying
to don't move
don't think about playing f6 there is a
big massive force in the position i want
to move my queen so i'm attacking your
bishop so you don't have time for queen
e2 so i can take on e4 i gotcha that's
what i'm that's what i'd like to do so i
just like to move my queen somewhere but
what's a good square right where do you
want to go none of them look
particularly appealing he has played one
he's played queen e7 so idea being but
the question
i think he's played between the e7
now the question is um
yes
is there oh and queen e7 bishop g2 has
been played so hicaro realizing that
that bishop could not
should not have been left on the b1
diagonal forced the bishop into a
passive
uh
square g2 yeah but that's not that
doesn't look like good news for wesley i
mean well hold on hold on f5 f5 is
begging to be played
and to try to break up the team
that's sitting on e6
d5 and c4 f5 is begging to be played
beautiful idea because then also notice
that uh g6 square exactly
i'm not sure i like the square f3 for
the bishop i think bishop f3 might have
been better it's a double-edged position
no question about it all results
possible still and wesley is stopping to
think that time is ticking down to
almost even with hikaru and this
position
very complex one you could see this in
an over the board game for sure but
wesley now pausing for too long before
finally playing rook to c1 finally
moving to keep ahead on the clock after
he played this movie he did not play f5
until he worked to c1 right now and and
this other game is interesting but let's
stay with this one see if this is a
fight for first bishop back to
to f1 well he might be able to rearrange
his bishop to e3 and then
yeah that's exactly what he's thinking
is thinking about putting the queen on
d1 putting the bishop on d3 locking that
pawn you know
that's right and he's played it so rook
b2
and uh queen d1 now it's not gonna
happen it's dangerous though it's c-pawn
but look at clean h5 checks
in the game but instead uh c2 wait c2 c2
c2 no way that allows the attack
straight oh my gosh
that's a horrible idea by hikari
g6 to stop this attack i think bishop d3
and i really like wesley's position but
what happens queen h5 and then king
g6
what are you doing g6 you're going to
sack on yeah you could i'm not yeah
queen h5 he's done the first move and
he's done the second move both on the
board and now
and now g6
g6 are there perks here is he gonna
what no white is trying to win this is
trying is there emergency exits well
first of all i think simply queen well
queen h4 i want to know knight g6 now
guys come on take that take that and go
well queen before we have we also have
some counter play of our own we might be
able to play rook b1 in these positions
and then after a bunch of captures we
have rook c1 at the end
um
oh i was saying if they're queen g4
yeah um we i was thinking we could play
rook b1 oh oh yeah and my king is on the
first rank right so i got to play
uh king dave who he sacrificed with him
bishop
he sacrificed with the bishop now he's
got to keep an eye on that b1 square
confidently
i think he needs to get in king g2 if
he's playing for the win
and king of fate played so if only we
could trade clean places with our knight
and our queen
wouldn't that be sweet i'm so i was t we
were teaching yesterday in all girls
school and somebody tried to uncastle
b1 is on
is now been stopped but here comes
another pawn with d3 and there goes the
age
black is actually slightly frozen
because he can't move his rook to b1
can't make anything happen with a c2
pawn it feels like white can always
perpet at will and so he's challenging
nakamura to find a move right now and
wesley's ahead on the clock as well and
by the way if the queen black queen
tries to get in the game don't leave
that e6 pawn hanging
that that's an important uh
shield naka realizing that he has to
deal with this threat and he found the
best move queen to e8 queen to e8
trying to trade off the most important
attacking piece
and bringing his rook potentially to the
to the defense as well on the seventh
rank well it's a trade of queens is
death to white okay well of course
of course i will play queen f6 check
you'll play king g8 and of course i'll
continue with wesley's plan right uh of
course why is he thinking so much
untouchable because
yes exactly i'm trying to bait you what
is he looking for he was up 20 seconds
on the clock and now he's dropped his
queen before
that's a very surprising move i i i
thought it was important that wesley
keep the initiative
with his queen on f6 uh by the way in
the other game kasparov
he's gone back here to g6 and he's he's
repeating moves trying to well you don't
gain time in the clock because it's a
delay not an increment
by the way uh 20 seconds
each
kasparov up an exchange in the other
game and looking to press on fabiano
and the players are sharing first
and
can
let's look at the other game quickly
though because we have almost no time on
the clock we've got to get to that game
gary kasparov an exchange up against u.s
champion fabiana cariwana
and exchange for no bomb oh my gosh why
did he play a4 he could have frozen you
could have frozen black's play he could
have frozen the knight on f6 with the
move rook f3 he didn't do it again time
the critical factor here
but white is so so well placed with the
past pawn
will he be able to do it as he's quickly
moving both sides quickly moving there
six seconds left for fobby in this
position sorry guys
oh he can play bishop d5 to
bishop d5 bishop g2 releasing his rook
from the e
from the defense of the h3 pawn and gary
has blundered his h3 pawn he didn't have
to allow this at all that's not better
but he's just not staying he's just
staying ahead on the clock just enough
god has a very
he's climbed his way
right back into this game all results
possible
and gary's got to find a move
he's got seven seconds left he's got to
go rook e8 b8 and get behind that pawn
and take that b6 pawn instead he's moved
his king over to the description
he has actually gotten the b-pawn but
now carrano with three connected passers
count those three good and now an offer
of a trade of rooks which must be
accepted
as we see there on the board attacking
the bishop savvy getting but bishop d5
crucial great
really really nice with just six seconds
on the clock that bishop on d5
you know controlling the h pawn that's
right there goes that pawn and oh my
goodness definitely bishop these two
kids looks like i mean this is what
there goes upon a winning position for
gary and now there goes a piece he's got
to take it gary's up will those go
anywhere no way
no way no way those pawns are going to
survive can't be rightful games
night back wow and now pinning the
knight
pawn up he stopped that guy from going
forward can he get anything and now he
sacrificed gary caspar
winning the game and sending caruana
into the basement as gary wow
finally pulled off the last game of the
day despite being in time pressure so
that puts gary in clear third that's
right behind our leaders is that right
everything's super bunched up right we
were expecting somebody to maybe have a
big lead by the end of the day but to
the contrary everybody is still hotly in
this competition look at gary totally
frustrated three blunders in three very
nice positions and he just feels like he
should be on top of this tournament
right now no way in the world he thinks
that he should be where he is but he's
only half a point out of first so he
doesn't have to feel badly about his
situation
at least he's not all the way down in
the cellar he's only half a point out of
first place
tremendous fight today but wesley and
nakamura with some tricks with some
blunders as is typical in blitz they're
standing even at five while gary at four
and a half and fabi who was cruising
when he first got three and a half did
he lose three games in a row it looks
like he just tumbled dramatically in
this third round of play today so five
points out of nine rounds that gives
them wesley and fabi plus one gary
kasparov at four and a half out of nine
leaves him with an even score and it's
fabiano giving the points to the
tournament leader says he's at minus two
it couldn't be tighter this competition
now don't go anywhere because we are
gonna have interviews with the players
after day one of the ultimate um blitz
challenge here in st louis um and also
tomorrow we're gonna go through the
whole thing again
gary must be thinking hey i could have
gotten nine points i think i think
that's exactly what gary is thinking
gary is going to be you know
kicking himself but let's face it he's
been out of professional chess for so
many years rusty yeah right rusty but
still formidable formidable at the
chessboard that's right and we've got so
many players tweeting in commenting
about this action john bartholomew says
sick action all players are battling
hard with the retired 53 year old gary
gaspara who is providing much of the
drama
and uh mike klein mentioned that after
grand master ricardo nakamura lost three
in a row he won after he lost the
renault he won three in a row to end up
tied for first at the end of the house
it's a streaky kind of chess you get on
a roll or you get on a tumble and we
have u.s champion in our studio that's
right
with fabiana caruana the u.s champion
the number two player in the world bobby
it looked like it was going swimmingly
in the first half and then all of a
sudden it collapsed where do you see
your major mistakes
i think every game had its mistakes um
the first game was pretty awful i i
missed a lot of chances to win i i mean
of course i could have also lost a lot
of games which i did win um but
yeah i mean it was all more or less
going
normally until the i lost three in a row
which isn't a good thing to do tell me
what happens what goes on in your mind
when you lose a game and then you
realize you want to hold it together and
then it looks like it keeps going in
that same direction how do you stop the
bleeding i mean you just wait until the
finish line it didn't look good when you
started losing game and then another
game and another one
i mean the games go pretty quickly it's
one game after the other and splits so
anything can happen um
so
yeah i think wesley also started with a
bunch of losses in the beginning he did
yeah and
as did knock up and how he's tied for
first yeah so i mean it
uh it's up and down um
but yeah just it's not very pleasant to
lose a bunch in a row you seem cooler
when you lose gary as we know it's very
emotional and he showed a lot of emotion
when he lost his games especially his
blundering pieces uh is that a strategy
for you to stay cool how do you feel
inside when this is going on it's not
pleasant but uh and what can you do
especially in blitz
uh these things just happen
oh all right well get yourself together
and there's always tomorrow nine more
rounds to go for you thanks
guys thank you maurice
wow i'm still a
nerd
a wild uh first
uh first day in the this ultimate blitz
championship that's what i mean i have
to say i'm really really impressed by
the games of gary and you just take away
one two three different moves
and we have a guy who's on cruise
control
amazing amazing performance by gary
kasparov i really admire the way he's
played just some
un just just blind spots those momentary
blind spots they're the only things
separating him from first and third and
he's in our studio well no actually
we've got another player a player who
just like fantastic
so i apologize i thought it was what yes
i apologize
we were with grandmaster wesley so who
looked like he was having trouble in the
beginning you look like you're trying to
find your form then you took the jacket
off and then all of a sudden things
started going your way
how did they how did they how did you
get out of this
jacket it's got to be the jacket it's
got to be the driver if you argue you
shouldn't have your jacket when you're
playing blitz anyway
um well it's not really about the jacket
but you know just it's kind of uh
more comfortable without you you know
just with the shirt without jab because
when you move your pieces you know you
have to be careful if you have your
jacket like that it might hit something
and you know it could cause
one of the pieces fell it could cause uh
trouble so
yeah maybe tomorrow i'll play again
without the jack
tell us how did you get your mind right
when you were when you were losing
that gift of a blunder of a piece by
caspar
you must have been really happy when you
were getting these gifts twice i uh
blundered this night
both games so
tomorrow
watch out for his bishop
now that he knows he's blundering the
night but um well actually i was
fighting for my life just you know
fighting hard fighting for my life
because
otherwise uh
you know i would end up in last place
here everybody is very strong i'm
playing world champions here and future
world champions so
i gotta keep fighting for my life and
you know when i started with zero two i
was thinking i might finish up with zero
out of nine so
i gotta play hard and uh
um
you seem relieved four and a half tied
for first after the first day is a
really good score
was it far enough for five sorry
yeah um
i'm really but i mean i was very nervous
yesterday i haven't uh i mean i'm not
very experienced with top level blitz
like this
of course the first time playing gary
kasperov was
nervous and i would say inexperience
but
tomorrow hopefully i'll play
better settle down one last question
what does it feel like playing the
legend gary kasparov do you feel his his
energy at the board his ferocity his
desire to win yes uh
even now that he's retired for such a
long time he's still got that uh
monstrosity in him and level of energy i
can only imagine
how other people how other players like
yasser feel like when he was playing
gary and his prime must be a terrible
feeling
it was indeed yeah i mean it's amazing
you know he was uh he's been retired for
a long time
almost 10 10 years and he's still very
good that's incredible so i can only
imagine back in his prime how
anatolic anatoly karpov feels like
everybody felt like back in the day well
thank you so much wesley congratulations
on your first place standing now and we
look forward to seeing you tomorrow keep
up the exciting commentary
i'll see you tomorrow we will
wesley seoul in first place and keep up
the exciting games wesley
extremely high quality of play you know
i mean this is just the most exciting
thing ever
um i think it's the most exciting and
entertaining
match that i've ever seen well blitz
chess as we know uh is the most popular
form of chess played all over the world
and to have such high level players
playing
you know six
games against one another um well
this is the most elite form of blitz
i've seen
in the chess world
this is a party it is a party and it is
going to continue tomorrow so
get excited guys and a player is having
a party it's like nakamura yes tie for
first after a really crazy day he's with
marie's
maybe the one with the craziest day so
far because it was up and then down and
then back up again hikaru you seem to be
doing all right and all of a sudden you
had a little rough patch in the middle
and we were wondering what's going on
what did you need to do to get back in
this tournament uh well i think first of
all my play was not not very good today
um i know it was up and down i found a
way to win some games but the positions
i had today uh they were not inspiring
um you know i think i think in the
middle of the turn what happens i mean
okay the first game against fabiano i
was
fine maybe a little bit worse than i was
drawing and i just saw the wrong wrong
piece on f8 and then i blundered i
should have lost that and then i found a
way to win in the scramble okay the
second game while i mean we all know
what happened in that one i'm in uh with
a certain certain move i mean but
have to give gary the benefit of the
doubt i mean okay it's a serious event
but so tell us why did you allow him to
make this night move and then let go and
then come back i mean by the rules
although although to be fair yasser
thought that he was allowed to let go
you know we argued here on the set i
said look if you let it go it's a
completed move why did you allow that to
happen well i mean it's it's scary after
all um first off and secondly i mean uh
maybe maybe i'm not treating this event
as seriously as he is i mean i feel like
if i did that maybe he won't it won't go
both ways but i mean okay i just trying
to be nice and give him the benefit of
the doubt i mean you hate to see a game
decided on a blunder like that um so so
yeah that's that's why and all right i
mean after that i i kind of um
yeah i played a bad game against wesley
lost that and then it just cascaded
downhill in a hurry um against fabian
and then gary i mean i just kind of
didn't play well um but but yeah i kind
of hung in there um
and uh yeah i beat i guess i beat
fabiano and then i beat gary i mean okay
the third game against gary was quite
ridiculous because i played a very good
game i was i think just winning on the
board on the clock and then um i just
kind of lost a long time like two
minutes i just like i lost my mind and i
messed the whole thing up and probably
should have lost that but um but but
yeah gary made made um made the last
blunder and so i won that and
last round i mean i drew with wesley so
it's it's okay i mean i i wouldn't say
it's
it's good or it's bad but considering
where i was i mean uh
i i certainly think i can do better
tomorrow i don't think too many people
are satisfied today with the result as
everybody's making mistakes that are big
for them tell me what does it feel like
playing casparo blitz in a competition
we haven't seen him play since nigel
short last year but he doesn't play so
much but he looks like he's putting
together some moves yeah i mean he's
he's still quite strong um
and certainly certainly in blitz i mean
uh if if he gets he gets his position
out of the opening i mean it's he's
still extremely dangerous um so i i
don't find it that surprising i mean i
guess the only thing for me is uh
actually i i haven't been feeling the
intensity the way that i was expecting
from him i i kind of was expecting
something a bit more uh a bit more so i
don't know that's the only thing that i
was surprised by i was expecting more to
be feeling more of the uh
more of the the energy that the passion
you know all that stuff that goes into
it but nevertheless i mean still uh
gary's gary's playing while he's still
still gary of course and uh you know if
you if you look at some of the older
players i mean even vishy he's he's four
or five years younger than gary and he's
still keeping it together so for me it's
it's not surprising at all that gary's
playing the way he is and uh
i think i mean for gary probably the
hardest part is i i don't think um
he's played in in tournaments like the
world blitz okay i think he played in st
john
st john a long time ago maybe 90 91
around there um but but like one of the
things with playing a lot of blitz games
in a row is especially when you're
playing top players is you make these
blunders and you have these streaks
these up and downs and it's very
important to stop the bleeding as
quickly as possible i mean that's that's
what i've learned from playing these
blitz events and i think if gary can do
that he's do that tomorrow especially
like you know if he hangs a knight hang
something i mean and loses if he can
keep it together and like keep it at one
game he's gonna have good chances
absolutely well thank you so much for
joining us sharing those thoughts and we
hope to see some more spectacular chess
and your quality chess tomorrow well i i
think i think we'll all play better
tomorrow
if i could draw your attention to your
screen for a second because we just like
to replay that moment for you and get
your thoughts as gary kasparov did make
this move night before and reach to
press the clock as you'll see right
there he reached to press the clock
and then brought his hand back
well you kind of smirk there because you
knew the rule in this moment
and then he played knight f4 but here
you see it in
more kind of a slow motion where he's
got and look he nearly pressed his clock
so his hand clearly
left the piece
but you didn't claim uh you just gave
him the benefit of dab you weren't
watching no no i i mean i know i i knew
he did it but um i mean i
i felt that it's not in the spirit of
the event i mean if
this was a serious competition i i would
have done something different but you
know
i mean maybe that's me being a little
bit too nice but uh i would hate to see
a game decided like that i mean he's
still gary and uh that's you know it's
it's what i it's what i did and that's
you know that's how it goes too nights
nakamura two nice nakamura in first
place
is that nickname gonna stick
much respect for that thank you so much
sure enjoy the evening and we look
forward to seeing you tomorrow thanks
okay yeah tomorrow i think um nakamura's
gonna be blood thirsty because what a
day though what a day
anybody could have been in first place
ikaru pulled it back and he was playing
more consistent and it was gary's
blunders that's right as far as concert
is pretty much tied i mean anybody can
win of the four players nine games
tomorrow yeah all we have is plus one
wow it's uh
it's a really been an incredible day um
and we have gary kasparov with maurice
with the 13th world champion gary
kasparov who has been retired now for
over 11 years with 11 years exactly and
gary
this was you back in the element playing
blitz certainly not like last year you
had
games against nigel short but these guys
were a step up what did it feel like
being in the ring today
oh i can tell you i don't blunder cheap
yeah it's it's look having 50 of the
blundering three pieces three nights yes
winning positions
very good positions indeed great okay
okay so is the
um
nearly winning i mean
anderson can happen blitz
yeah it's um and also i i was quite
upset you know just uh missing a win
against carolina i played great game
with black pieces yeah so
um look you know i'm rusty so it's uh
definitely you know i'm i'm fighting
players that are you know way ahead of
anatolia or nigel
those are the only two events that i had
you know in the last 10 years
but you know i i think i'm i'm quite
pleased you know with what i did because
you know i had them on the ropes so just
you know blundering three nights it's
just you know it's a lot and this is the
games we saw
especially the second one we saw i mean
just it was such a bad you know moment
because i played a great game so i spent
a lot of time calculating knight f6
check instead of d1 again i don't know
what it i couldn't figure it out whether
it works but afterwards the one a five
knight f6 works for sure because then i
i saw that i can you know do take take
they're gonna see the queen c3
you know and this e5 knight takes c5 and
it's winning because my rook eventually
controls d4 square so i was very proud
that i calculated such a great
combination again maybe i made just it's
it's a mistake but uh but it's um you
know but then i got position which was
technical i had my knight on d6
and it's ironically blunder this night
right beautiful yeah and it's it's it's
it's you know it's actually you know
playing b7 because there's
move earlier b7 and he couldn't take on
d6 because then i taken bishop before
winning you know this is the the the
piece otherwise bishop to xc5 has a
threat and then rook c8 and i'm just
again winning you have lots of
opportunities in this game yeah but is
this yeah but is it the time is it the
time though is it because you seem to
also be spending a lot of time on the
clock your time was ticking down you'd
have less than a minute in dominating
positions but but that would seem to
cost you as you have to pick up the pace
trying to make sure you found the win
yes it's got also a lot of pressure
because you know i'm just getting tired
so this is again it's nine you know nine
games and it's each game is kind of kind
of a show and i fought in all games um
and you know
you know
missing chances obviously my opponents
also you know could complain but again i
missed big and um it's also period with
cicar with the second game you know i i
i because the the
the gap between between rounds is so
short so i couldn't recover after this
this this blunder with with wesley just
in the previous round so and i was i was
playing first in a first uh a few
minutes and we see your reaction here
yeah yes in the game you were quite
shocked when it happened no no first few
minutes i played poorly but then
actually you know having about 20
seconds i played a great game i you know
i have him on the ropes you know just
you know he missed c3 and this is you
know and it was winning you know just
anything so i think the simplest was at
one point rook c5 and resigned so
instead of kingston rook c5 you know he
resigns because you know i just you know
i exchanged rooks otherwise made on c1
and at extra exchange and that would be
very different tournament
tell us about this moment with ikaru
when you let go of the piece wait i
wasn't sure what i guess this is no i i
looked at the arbiter so if i
it's you know
probably i just you know i don't know
it's very difficult when you play blitz
to say whether your hand was off or not
well but we have it on camera so it's
easy enough no no no no no
no i didn't know that's that's why i
looked and looked at hikara looked at at
uh the the referees so they did they
said nothing so it's there so they had
if they had claimed it and
just it was always the very next game it
[Laughter]
a very very nice positional draw i mean
just it's this was rookie eight rooks
here okay
again it's uh it was not the best game
he car actually played very well so it
was before i mean this is i
i was quite upset that i let him play
before before so i probably had to play
five first again despite blundering
three nights in the in the competition
so far you're only a half a point out of
first
how do you feel playing against these
players these are top ten players in the
world we're not just talking about
anybody you're playing three of the top
ten players in the world does it compare
to your heyday how do you feel right now
playing against because you're like the
michael jordan of chess people would
compare it playing against steph curry
or lebron james to some of the finest
players we have now how does it feel
back in the ring with these top players
look um i think it's a good show and
this it's i think san luis deserves you
know just as a capital of the world just
you know to have the best chess shows on
the planet so and i was you know very
happy as to when the when uh this idea
you know was floating around and i
thought okay look i have nothing to lose
so again it's just okay i can lose many
games i can wander many nights yes but
uh um but uh you know i'm i'm enjoying
myself so it seems that you know i'm
competing so again it's this it's it's
not you know
total dominance as some predicted it's
not total disaster others predicted so
i'm just you know am i on a solid 50
percent you know with uh with a few
pieces blundered in the nine rounds so
um
let's see what happens tomorrow so i you
know i have probably better feelings now
but obviously you know these guys you
know they they you know they are much
better trained you know to play a longer
event so we'll see what happens tomorrow
we will see thank you so much for your
time with us and for entertaining us
still with your great play and let's
hope you keep on to those nights
tomorrow
indeed one of the great players yes gary
i can't help but remark i mean i think
you're stealing the show quite frankly i
really do i think your games in
particular have been the most dynamic of
any of the four players forget about
your blundering your knights but how do
you do that with these strong players
creating the positions that are the most
interesting on the board in getting
chances in all the games i mean
it's it's almost a kind of magic these
are really really the elite players of
the world and you're getting great
dynamic positions and
and we find ourselves absorbed by your
game and your opening play by the way
you're playing principled openings every
time there's no avoiding principle okay
though i just i
obviously tried it with berlin
because these guys they you know they
they play berlin you know day and night
so this is this is i think 50 of the
games in in top tournaments now is
berlin so i thought it would not it
wouldn't make any sense for me to
compete with them in the positions that
they know you know just you know from
top to bottom so um i thought that
playing you know something you know
refreshing something more open you know
you know creating christ central at
early uh stage you know would
would be challenging for them and
actually it worked
absolutely did work you're getting great
positions playing well we hope to see
you clean up those mistakes and
entertain us again tomorrow thank you
gary kasparov 13th world champion one of
the greatest players ever many think it
is definitely the greatest player ever
given his record of dominance over the
years still entertaining us with
fantastic chess thank you gary fantastic
really
how do you feel did he steal the show
absolutely i think i mean it's not even
close right yeah everybody was talking
about it in the comment threads on
twitter
they were like wow gary where have you
been i know think of what we've missed
over the last 11 years by the way
wow
so impressed
and we've got uh maurice ashley with his
final thoughts on today's ultimate blitz
in st louis
well it's just been extraordinary
watching like i said the michael jordan
of chess play against the current
all-stars yes there were mistakes it's
blitz after all the games have gone up
and down sideways amazing thrills
fantastic time pressure saves just
simply a wonderful day of chess this is
the kind of show that we love to do
commentary on and i can't wait till
tomorrow it's just gonna be nine more
exciting rounds just fantastic day
that's right this is what can make chess
popular so if you have a friend and they
think chess is boring tomorrow is the
time for them to tune in just watch the
show drag them over so be with us
tomorrow the clocks are going to start
again at one central time and two in the
east coast but we'll have our pregame
show starting at 12 50. see you at the
ultimate blitz challenge here in st
louis tomorrow
good afternoon
[Music]
you